during yesterday's show we did a segment
about the
pennsylvania district attorney's races
so
a big race coming out of philadelphia
and there was some optimism it actually
looked like the moderate democrat could
win isn't it funny us cheering for a
moderate democrat why well
you're not gonna get a republican d.a
but there was a far-left
pro-black lives matter district attorney
who had been in
crime had been skyrocketing violent
crime really horrifying stories out of
philly as most of you know we used to do
the show just outside of philly in the
philly suburbs
and one of the reasons we left was the
well rising out of control crime
namely the riots but there were a bunch
of shootouts and i was just like yo i
don't want to be in a city we want to
get into the middle of nowhere and kind
of just have more space
grow the company do something so then lo
and behold the story comes out
it was a blowout the progressive won by
30
points that means even with all of the
skyrocketing crime
all of these riots the tearing down of
statues
and the people said we're not going far
left enough let's go
far left er i'm not surprised a lot of
people just don't pay attention so we'll
we'll talk about that but we do have
some good news that
that uh individual who wrote the 1619
project just had
her tenure rescinded it was a proposal
apparently was was
not picked up journalists are outraged
they're furious they believe that this
woman is a hero but
apparently people started to realize the
1619 project is fake news
and for this no tenure so it's not all
bad news we're gonna talk about this and
we got
one of the best people to talk about
what's going on in pennsylvania we have
now senate candidate for pennsylvania
sean parnell
hello tim it is great to be back uh what
this is like
my fourth fourth now fourth time on the
show
right and and what i mean as most
political candidates would probably be
scared to come down and and sit
in a studio with you because as you say
you're a disaffected liberal and nobody
wants to get ambushed with gotcha
questions but
you first of all you don't do that right
you're very very fair and i think that's
why
people actually watch your show as much
as they do i think well i really do
think that there is a a
a thirst for truth out there you said
people don't pay attention i think part
of the reason why they don't
is people are sick of the divisiveness
most people feel like that the news that
they watch on tv is not accurate and by
the way
like republican democrat left leaning
right leaning uh
i think people want the facts and they
want to be able to make decisions
on their own and so i think that's why
people watch i think the big question
for people who watch the show
or the issue is more are you paying
attention to what's really going on
there's a political establishment
and on the republican side you have a
very powerful anti-establishment force
that's pushed its way in and that's made
the neocons and the establishment
republicans run to the democrats
so this is why you could have a
disaffected liberal who's like yo the
media is lying about this that or
otherwise
and then we end up getting along even if
we disagree on policy you know i'm not
here to to push an
agenda or narrative to help someone win
i want to understand the truth and make
sure that
you know things work so that's what
that's why this show works i think
i think that and i think that should be
the goal of every journalist i mean
you know one of the things that you
learn you know and and by the way
you know but i'm not sure that your
audience does but i am not
a career politician i'm being a
politician was never part of my
professional track or even running for
political office but you learn pretty
quickly when you run
that the media on either side of the
aisle they definitely have a narrative
and they're definitely pushing that
narrative and sometimes the facts are
pushed to the sidelines in pursuit of
that and i don't like that
yeah you know i mean usually sometimes
you're not one of those people when
you're you're a journalist you do this i
mean
and there are some good journalists out
there that that i rely on
and that are even some democrats out
there that i know these journalists are
democrats
that write fair right and to me that's
you know that's the benchmark like i
don't care if you're democrat or
republican
just be fair it's a question of scruples
do people feel that that you know
feeling in your gut when they know
they're doing something wrong and the
problem is too many people in this
country today
don't so they're sitting there like well
i know i'm lying but who cares and
that's what you get so
we'll get in all this stuff but uh also
i think you you know a lot about what's
going on with these da races that's
crime the black lives matter stuff so
we'll talk about that
we got that we got ian all over glasses
ian crossland over here in full clark
kent get up happy to be here
yes i'm in the corner as well pushing
buttons to make this show happen happen
to be happy to be here
before we get started we actually have a
sponsor today check out
strongerbonesandlife.com
and you can get 51 percent off of this
really great ageless multi-collagen you
know we shout them out all the time ian
actually just threw some in his coffee
so creamy
because he loves putting it in there and
i love mixing it in my drink smoothies
we got a slushy machine now
so uh look when you when you're you're a
35 year old skater and you want to keep
your bones and skin
and joints healthy this is what you need
you need more you you need this ageless
multi-collagen because it
makes up the most important part of your
you know skeletal system and good hair i
mean
you know i know that the the ladies out
there probably concerned about having
their skin look good and nice you want
some collagen but i'm sure the men out
there want to still look good at 35 or
getting older
take that collagen go to stronger bones
in life dot com
you can get 51 off they say you got a 61
i'm sorry a 60 day money back guarantee
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits
for every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date
biotrust has provided over 4.4 million
meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
it is non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners and free of free of
gluten antibiotics and
rbgh and rbst no odor or taste unlike
bone broth and other collagen
supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
collagen supplements
free shipping with every order and this
is really cool free vip
life free vip live health and fitness
coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches
for life with every order and they got a
new report on e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin
with every order so if you want to take
your health seriously and you want to
get back into you know getting
physically active getting out there in
the world with now
all the restrictions coming down go to
strongerbonesandlife.com 51
off and thank you to biotrust for
sponsoring the show but don't forget
also
go to timcast.com become a member by
clicking this big old members only
button and you get access to the members
only
area where we have a bunch of exclusive
segments a huge library of content we
got a ton of awesome people going back
a ways some full podcast episodes when
you sign up you're helping us grow the
business we've got new shows on the
horizon we're doing a lot to expand
we're really really close
to doing live friday night events every
friday night we're going to have a live
event
where members will be able to come out
but it'll be
with restrictions like we can only do
like 20 people per week so it'll be kind
of difficult but it will be available so
make sure you suddenly become
become a member because you never know
we'll put up a notice saying boom
tickets are available
and don't forget to like share subscribe
hit the notification bell
leave us a good review on itunes spotify
give us five stars if you really like
the show but let's jump into that first
big story
i can't say i'm surprised the daily
caller reports after a surge in
violent crime progressives win big in
pennsylvania's largest city
i i i couldn't believe it because um you
had this police-backed moderate democrat
guy
and he's and and the the the polls are
like it's fairly even he's like he's
doing all right
and i was like this guy's my opinion i
thought i was going to win because you
have all this crime
i remember what happened in south philly
do you remember when the when the
christopher columbus statue was
yes yes and then you had a bunch of
these like local dudes standing around
saying
back off the city came and took it down
i i had to believe
that regular people were like yo what
are you doing
this is this this makes me a bit
pessimistic because it wasn't just
that the progressive the far left pro
black lives matter guy won
it was a blowout was it 30 plus points
so what what's happened in this place
are these do these people really want
more crime do they like the crime that's
happening in their state
no i mean i think it's important to
remember that it's a
it's a democrat primary right so
whoever's the
in the democrat primary in today's day
and age you know
the litmus test is you know if you're
running for senate is
is like nuking the filibuster or packing
the supreme court or
tearing down fundamental institutions
that have been a part of this country
for the last 200 years so it's it's it's
democrat primaries
are becoming what did you say like who
can be lefter
who can be far lefter well krasner i
mean you're looking at the
city of philadelphia what happened
what's happened to that city
under krasner's is sad right i mean i
think you're seeing something like a 30
percent rise in crime
violent crime in philadelphia uh the
people there are struggling
i think when there's a rise in crime you
see you know
the black communities are
disproportionately affected by that
so it's unfortunate to see him uh as the
the the guy right um
it's the ultra wealthy backing these
people too like krasner i think was
backed by one of the soros foundations
or by wealthy individuals
yes and i think late in the game i think
an infusion of something like you know i
don't know this for sure but something
like three million dollars
to help him get across the finish line
and and look that
is and i'm not judging that right like
you have to raise money
to win in politics and not you know and
the more effective a a
candidate is on a campaign at raising
money the more effective they
they can be at getting their message out
now i i liken it no
everything that i use is like a military
analogy and i'm not advocating for any
sort of violence right but dollars
dollars in a campaign uh are like
bullets in a gun right when
your platoon is out there in combat you
run out of ammo you can't respond to the
enemy you can't defend yourself the same
is true in politics you run out of money
look the the democrats well in my case
the democrats will come after you
and they will bludgeon you with ads and
inhibit if you have no money you can't
respond
and so that what happened in
philadelphia this is this is
a prime example of that and and and the
profound
impact that that money can have in terms
of advertising and moving the needle one
way or the other
it's like uh reminds me of fouchy
he says are you going to do the voucher
impression no do the fact
fiochi tells everyone to go on cruises
he tells everybody not to wear masks
and then he blames donald trump they
blame donald trump it's like trump was
just taking this guy's advice but
i'll pass the buck to trump he should
have fired the guy in the first place i
bring him up
because these voters are like fouchy
followers right so here's what i mean
when you see the cdc say all right y'all
can take your masks off if you're
vaccinated and these people are
literally saying no no we shouldn't we
should keep them on
you can see that with your eyes that is
a democratic base
that doesn't care about what the
guidelines are they just care about what
signifies their tribe like david hogg
said he doesn't want to be seen as a
conservative so i'll just wear the mask
anyway
what you can't see is the virtue
signaling
and the tribalism that's not tangible
which is elections like this the ads
come out
they say ridiculous nonsense and out of
context garbage and people just go
whatever you say they would rather just
align themselves
tribally than care about anything
principally that would
help better their community so i i would
say
that's why you know on you know what in
my any any part of my campaign right
like
i go everywhere i'm just using myself as
an example i go everywhere i talk to
everyone i personally believe that
leadership is about
yeah of course coalition coalition
building where people agree with you
uh but it's also about going where
people don't and building consensus
right and giving those folks a chance to
get to know you with the understanding
that of course as americans
we're not going to agree on every issue
right but
the leaders show up anyway to show
people that they care and so
when when i campaign when i go out there
i go everywhere
with the democrat independent republican
i don't care if you believe in the
greatness of america if you believe
in freedom if you believe in the idea of
you know
passing down a a rich vibrant country a
country that's rich with opportunity to
the next generation then join us join
the movement and i think what we've been
a
because we've been able to do that and
part of that by the way is
think for yourself right don't don't
just lock into
you know left-wing media or right-wing
media read
think for yourself part of being a part
of this movement that i think we're
trying to create in western pennsylvania
and indeed we probably have created it
of thousands of people in western
pennsylvania
people from across the political
spectrum is they want the truth
and they're going to seek it out
themselves and then not only that
they're going to take action
to make their communities better and in
this case you know so what does that
look like for a campaign it means like
they're out there knocking doors
they're out there hosting events they're
out there making phone calls right
um they're helping move the ball down
the field something that democrats have
done
for years far better than republicans
right is organized right definitely
they're better at it
but but so we're we're rivaling that in
pennsylvania and i think that you saw
that reflected
in these ballot questions so krasner
yeah what happened with krasner
he's that progressive guy yeah he's the
progressive guy that wanted philadelphia
it's it's a bad thing for philadelphia
that he won i think he's one of the
worst da's in philadelphia history but
that's
besides the point i think the real
indicator uh in pennsylvania statewide
is we had two ballot questions on the
ballot
right which both ballot questions
pertain to the governor's
unilateral ability to extend emergency
declarations in pennsylvania you can do
that in perpetuity and he's
i would argue that he's abused the
process right like of course covid was
real we had to take it seriously and
there were
early on those emergency provisions were
certainly appropriate right
but it's you know 15 days to slow the
spread is turned into 15 months right
and so
so my point is tim is that republicans
showed up in force
in one but it was really what i see that
as a referendum on tom wolf who's
radical democratic governor
we won those ballot initiatives by
around 139
000 votes statewide that's significant
and it's indicative of the strength of
the republican party
didn't wolf kill a bunch of old people
so the
state of pennsylvania and so to your
point of like
how president trump was blamed for his
covet response
uh you know the time like first of all
governor cuomo right now is under the
microscope
the the second highest nursing home
deaths in the country
happened in the state of pennsylvania
under governor tom wolf no one's talking
about it but believe me
in the near future they will be with the
governor's race coming up now
uh but i think what was particularly
disconcerting
about nursing home policy is of course
if you were paying attention to covet
early on
you saw how it was i mean it first came
to seattle right
we saw it tear through nursing home
facilities and how the elderly
were particularly vulnerable when it
comes to
covet right we knew we knew that and
you had secretary levine our secretary
of health in pennsylvania for the wolf
administration
saw that coming and she took her own
mother out of a nursing home facility
while leaving other senior citizens in
the state of pennsylvania to languish
and die i got real problems with that
and so
you know i don't think the venus with
the biden administration
now she's with the biden administration
and so uh you know i don't think we're
talking enough
about that there are a litany of things
that we could have probably done better
that we definitely could have
we could have done better and by the way
um it's easy to be a monday morning
quarterback
this is i am giving a little bit of
grace here and that this is a hundred
year once in a hundred year pandemic
we've never faced anything like this
before we didn't really know what covid
was like early on so precautions i
thought were necessary early on
but look it only took about three to
four months for us to realize
you know for us to learn a heck of a lot
more about covet right and as you're
as as as you're dealing with the
pandemic your strategy has to evolve
as the science evolves as you learn more
about the virus that didn't happen in
pennsylvania and
elderly senior citizens uh and the
citizens of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania i think they paid the price
yeah i think we got the worst of every
world with fauci because
at first he's like don't wear your masks
there it is i knew i knew it was coming
the cruises it's fine can i just do the
slow clap am i allowed to clap
beautiful imagine if he came out right
away and said just wear masks in case
let's be on the safe side of these
things then what we were we would have
reduced a dramatic amount of death i met
if you imagine if it was like hey you
probably shouldn't go on cruises right
now until we figure this thing out
very early on he was like it's fine and
then
a month later when it gets bad then he's
like okay now it might get bad
then when we start we see texas in
florida and it's like
you know people are asking why is it
texas and florida are doing so well
no answer we don't really know the uh
the uh today show did a segment where
they were like we're not entirely sure
just ending the restrictions and for
some reason cova deaths are going down
perhaps it was because we learned that
transmission indoors was worse outdoors
was safer
getting vitamin d and exercise was
better for you and people were put in
the worst possible position
where was fouchu to be like maybe we
should change our minds on the seat
he was too lacks in the beginning and
too harsh near in the middle to the end
so people have been following this guy
playing simon says where are you don't
wear any masks
wear your masks double mask no don't
double mask
double mask anyway if you get the
vaccine wear your mask anyway okay i
admit it i was just saying that i didn't
that's where we're at right now and and
i think yeah i i agree
um i i think fauci has been
remarkably inconsistent in in his
guidance right
um and i think at the end of the day
with a pandemic response now
here's my thing if you if you again i
thought that the 15 days to slow the
spread when we didn't know a lot about
the virus was probably appropriate early
on but you've got to adjust fire pretty
quickly right um
but but i i think he's been inconsistent
uh and truthfully the science behind
masking is is truth it's dubious at best
it really is and so um the mask
in in today's day and age even with when
you're seeing the cdc changing their
mass guidance saying that okay
now that people are vaccinated you don't
have to wear a mask outside
you don't have to wear i mean look if
you want to wear a mask
wear a mask i'm not going to judge you
on that like if you if you feel safer
wearing a mask go right ahead and do it
but what the point that i'm building to
is that is that
it's there's all of us to assess the
risk
that is tolerable for us but what was
the updated science that made the cdc
change their minds because i didn't see
it
and that that was exactly that's exactly
the point that i was building to is that
the cdc changed their guidance
right uh with real really no
justification in the empirical science
we were given no reason why it was just
it really was the cdc director i think
on a on a cable news show saying like
the science has evolved so what we saw
with fauci
was that there was a one interview where
he was asked should people wear two
masks and he's like well it's just
common sense if you wear two masks
then he gets asked again no no there's
nothing saying to wear two masks
then he comes out again yeah everybody
should wear two masks and all of a
sudden people just wear two masks it's
like they're playing simon says with
this guy
he is one of the worst most dangerous
individuals in this country
and you want to you want something
really freaky i saw this out of dallas
there's a video that somewhat purports
to show
like two guys in the army going into a
7-eleven and like randomly giving a dude
a vaccine
and my question is like at what point
did we go from
you can't speak positively about certain
medications
like when trump was talking about
hydroxychloroquine youtube was like
we'll ban you if you bring it up don't
even talk about it
and now you've got people being like
outside of a 7-eleven just being like
without
consulting your doctor they're going to
give you a medication i'm like nah come
on you can't do that can you like you
got
people talk to their doctors before they
get this stuff really not anymore well
well of course of course i mean i i
agree well it's it's
look yes double standards
um and you know ultimately
dr fauci you know i i don't know i like
i like to think that that he did his
best
but to me i think he's i think i think
that there were political intentions
behind some of the decisions he was
making i mean i will tell you this
certainly
the radical left uh weaponized the virus
in a way that they thought would benefit
them right no definitely
um and never let a good crisis go to
waste and uh that's that is
part of their their playbook right and
and so
i i don't know i i i'm glad to see that
we're
that we're coming out of this even
though people are reluctant to take off
the mass but again if people want to
wear a mask
uh fine if if you feel like you're high
risk fine but
but it should be something i i just want
to say though you know going back to
this this this
there's some there's a positive note in
this progressive winning that maybe
we're not seeing maybe we're looking too
much at the surface level
a 30-point blowout could it be that many
people have left the democratic party
and the only people that remain are
progressives so we're not seeing a
landslide victory for the d.a
we're actually seeing the moderate
democrats having quit saying i don't
know i'm republican now
i i think it's a great point i mean that
what i think
you're seeing is this is where the
democrat
base is right now it is it is
it is largely out of touch with
everyday americans on either side of the
aisle specifically
the blue-collar people unions that they
building trade unions that they purport
to represent
you know for for a long time by the way
police officers especially in the state
of pennsylvania where they're unions
like when they're fraternal order of
police like in in western pennsylvania
it's fop one fop three
uh out in philadelphia i think it's fop
five uh
there's like a 50 50 split of democrat
republicans maybe maybe even more
democrats than republicans that are cops
i think you'd be hard-pressed to find a
police officer supporting democrat cause
so my to my point
moderate democrats i think there there
there is no
there's not a home for them really in
the democratic party i mean now now
listen
you know my i come from a family
that that that grew up in allegheny
county half of them are allegheny county
democrats
their blue dog what they say old school
blue dog democrats pro-life pro-gun
democrats a lot of those people feel
like they don't have a home
in the democrat party today so we try to
give them a home with us and we try to
actually be that voice that the building
trade unions
uh don't have anymore in the democrat
party now it takes work and time and
effort but we're we're trying to do that
so
yes i do i think i'm right actually i
pulled up the data and i think i'm right
check this out the democratic primary
that just happened is lawrence krasner
versus carlos vega carlos vega was
backed by the police unions
he was at the polls said it was really
close
the total votes for this primary was 129
865 votes let's go back to the previous
election
the democratic primary in 2017 the total
votes was
two 155 and forty six now it's possible
that it was a hundred and fifty five
thousand because there were more people
listed in the primary and so some people
who normally don't vote might show up
for one of these individuals
but i actually think what we're seeing
is around there's around 26 000
less votes than there was last time i'm
willing to bet a lot of people just said
i don't vote
i don't vote uh democrat anymore yeah i
mean so they weren't in the primary at
all
it's a it's a midterm well it's an
off-cycle election so turnout is usually
down although i will say
if you look at the republican turnout
this year
i i think there was something like i
don't know i look over at my campaign
manager who's over there
uh he's my partner in crime on on all
this stuff but i think there was
something like 855 000 republicans that
turned out and if you look back
at like 2009 right which i think was
another off-cycle election i think
turnout for the republican party back
then was something like 500 000. so
you're looking at the difference in
turnout there right
like we're doing everything we can to
organize and unite this party and bring
people together and
and be the big ten party that i think
the republican party has always intended
to be
right oh what were we going to say no i
mean we're the big ten party because i
think we're the party of individual
freedom right now
sovereignty how was it there ever how
was it ever there's somebody running on
a post
that to me is crazy in this day and age
it is but it it
is common in off-cycle elections so i'm
looking at this general election for uh
city controller
rebecca renhart only candidate listed
isn't it where in philly yeah philly
general election for the philadelphia
city controller there's no just one
person
like you literally could have walked at
me like i guess i'll run why not and
then you may have actually won because
people would be like i'll vote for the
other person
yeah i mean it's it's yes our elections
are broken man well
i don't know that there i don't there
are issues right
um there there's no question about that
although talking about election
integrity in today's day and age
i'm not even talking about integrity i'm
just talking about our culture the
popularity
contest yeah like look at this guy so
let me let me go back to the uh the
krasner thing here
that how many how many how many votes in
the republican primary in philly do you
think there were
there was a hundred and twenty nine
thousand democratic primary votes
for the republican primary how many how
many votes do you think there were um
i don't know random guess votes in
philadelphia
primary 129 000 people voted in the
democratic primary voted in the
democratic philadelphia in philadelphia
how many people vote in the republican
primary
wait so the democratic primary democrats
had 129 000 people's turnout total votes
right on the democrat side yes
so i would say 30 of that number so
probably
15 000 20 000 9404
so republicans can't even go out and
vote in these cities at all
i think the reality is apathy no one's
engaging this this process
and so you've got people like us people
who are watching this show who are
active and paying attention
who are trying as hard as possible to
like push back on the tsunami
but the tsunami is apathy it's people
just sitting there lazy eyes half closed
ignoring the problems around them mitch
mcconnell gives the republican party a
horrible name because
it is it should be the party of rock
stars right now like it needs a
resurgence culturally where it's
exciting and like you think of youth and
and fun which is what the democrats
basically do with obama as well
here's here's what's funny the the the
democratic party used to be
the celebrities the rock stars but
they've all become rather square incen
and what i mean by that is like well
within the box they don't draw outside
the lines anymore
no more punk rock to see these punk rock
people support amazon and like you know
yeah it's not
i totally agree i think i think
conservatives like the
the republican party that i'm a part of
like
we're the new punk rock we're the party
of the american working class well
no you might be but mitch mcconnell
lindsey graham aren't they're the
opposite
well i mean look they've been around for
a long time right i mean
and they have they've got responsibility
at the top as leadership and trying to
bring people together and
in the republican party because we're an
ideological diverse party
it's very it could be very very hard to
do that like and you're looking at the
vote today on on the january 6
commission right
democrats rarely and i mean rarely if
ever break ranks their messaging is
almost
always the same they're like the borg if
you've ever watched star trek right
there
their messaging is on point their
organizing is on point they rarely break
break ranks and because of that they're
very effective now they've got the media
to help them do that right as sort of
the fly top cover for them but
republicans
sometimes it can be like herding cats
because we are the party of ideological
diversity we all believe different
things
you know you're welcome in the
republican party as long as i mean to me
i think you know the base litmus test is
you got to be small government more
freedom kind of person
you know but uh let me jump to the story
from the wall street journal house
back's creation of commission
on january 6th capital riot former
president trump and gop leaders urged
republicans to oppose the bill
so we're going to have some kind of what
9 11 style commission
on the capital riots and i'm sorry man
the the republican party i understand
it's it's it's
better than the democrats for a lot of
reasons but why didn't they ever do
anything about black lives matter antifa
when they had the power to do it
well we never really had the power to do
it under under president trump
um 2017. well i mean they weren't paying
attention the firs
well the first two years of of the trump
administration i mean i would argue that
the the black lives matter and antifa
protests that really rampaged across the
country
burned down federal courthouses they
burned down a police precinct and i
think minnesota i mean they they were it
was last year though so
republicans had lost the house at that
point but that's what i mean i mean i
think that most
of the violent protests that we saw
happened after the republicans had lost
control of all the
three branches of government how many
how many how many uh riots were there
over the past four years from far
leftists i don't know if the top 100s
i'm well i mean i would say probably
thousands i would absolutely say
thousands that just not a single one
not a single instance in from you know
in
2017 and 2018 warranted two republicans
any kind of action but the democrats get
one and they are going nuclear for
months a 9 11 style commission this is
the problem the democrats will
will like will stub their toe and blame
the far right and scream they have their
lungs and the republicans go okay
okay okay and then you can literally get
billions of dollars of damage and
the republicans won't even send in
national guard to stop it
trump will be like please please in the
national guard and the democrats in
these cities are like no and he goes
okay well i mean i think part of the
reason for that
is that the democrat party i mean
they have the largest super pac in the
world i mean they have
you know a billion dollar corporate
media mainstream media that does nothing
but fly cover for them and it in in
parrot their talking points right sure
sure but why why do republican
candidates care more about the opinions
of the new york times and their own
constituents
that so look it's it's a great question
and it's part of what i think the
republican party
i mean look if you're a candidate right
and you're going to go out there on the
parapet
be a republican be a conservative in
this day and age
you have to know going into him that if
the media the main not all the media
right and i'm i'm not trying to
they're i'm not trying to paint anybody
with you know broad strokes here
but you got to know that the media is
coming after you definitely and you're
not doing your job
you know that if they are coming after
you you're probably
over the target so to speak to use
military parlance right
that's how i look at things if they're
attacking me i know that i'm
representing the people and to me
ultimately that's what this job is about
this job is about
is about representing the people and
being there for them which is why
i mean look i think 2020 like running
a campaign in 2020 was an unbelievable
experience for me
because i didn't know anything about
campaigning it was the first time i've
ever done it so i learned a lot
but one of the things you know one of
the things that's just so important for
republicans right moving forward is
is is not being beholden to
like the the big money right we had 45
000 individual donors because of that we
weren't really beholden to
you know any sort of special interest
corporation or even the republican party
even though
i'm a republican running on the ticket
it gave me the freedom
to to represent the people in the best
way that i
saw fit and i think we did that to great
effect and we're going to take it to the
next level on the senate race but
yes you as a republican in this day and
age
you know you have to be willing to stand
on the parapet and take shots from the
from the media because
if you're advocating for for what you
believe and what the people that you
represent believe you're gonna take
they're coming after you i just got very
little faith in uh
anyone to actually be a leader in terms
of
standing up to the establishment which
is mostly democrat some republicans
there's a reason why people like
marjorie taylor green even after
everything she posted and said and then
apologized for
and it's because she's feisty she's a
fighter she fights she fights like
donald trump fought
and so she raises what three point
something million dollars in the first
quarter
so they can criticize her and smear her
all she wants and she revels in it
and people see that and they're like
finally someone is standing up
but ted cruz goes to cancun or whatever
right
so it's got the power outage the freeze
in texas
ted cruz flies so he flew to cancun is
that where he went yeah i think
just to take his family down there
regardless the media freaks out and then
he's flying right back overnight
i'd have been like you know what not the
media's freaking out i'm gonna take a
picture of myself my feet up
sipping a martini being like is this
what you want don't play stupid games
now he said he was just there to fly his
family there and back sure whether you
want to believe him or not
i think he was going on vacation and
honestly i don't care what makes what
you know what i do care about
well i'll say this first probably a bad
move
to be a representative of your community
in a time of crisis and be like
i'm gonna go to the beach nah i'd like
you know running for
office being in office is more than just
showing up in congress and talking
it's being a leader for your community
and and helping build that culture
and lead by example but if you want to
go on vacation i'm not going to cry
about it
i'll tell you what really bothers me
that the media screamed and he was right
back
oh no no oh geez no oh don't look at me
i don't care what the new york times has
to say
about these people i'm sick of the lies
from the media i'm sick of the of the
fact that
for for four years the republicans in
the senate
didn't do much of anything with what was
going on i remember
from 2016 1718 we knew censorship was a
very serious problem
and the banning of donald trump's most
ardent supporters was going to result in
republicans getting
defeated republicans can't even express
their own opinions
how could they expect to win at this
point and they did not agree
look look i know i know you know where
i'm at you know where i'm going with it
right like it's happening to me right
now you know i
look if you you want to think you talk
about big tech censorship i
i'm not i'm not section 230 is one thing
i don't think i necessarily support that
because it hurts people like you right
like
but they're the repeal of section two of
there or yeah they're repealing section
230 hurts
it needs to be reformed it needs to be
reformed for sure right something needs
to be done about big time or state level
laws which we're seeing
yes but look at what's happening to me
i'm a senate i'm a senate candidate
in the state of pennsylvania in the
arguably
the biggest senate race in the country
right senate control
depends on the state of pennsylvania
right and go to google right now
right punt just do it right now for you
for your viewers like
search sean parnell senate on google and
see if you can find my campaign
website nbc news is the first link
twitter account so i raise money
on my campaign site the only way i raise
digital money
is on that campaign side google has a
monopoly on search engines right so you
go and go you
you gotta be a forensic data analyst to
find my website on google now
if you're watching the show go to yahoo
or go to bing or go to duckduckgo
and punch in sean parnell senate and see
what comes up
let's go to bing yeah just just see just
see what comes out bing
sean parnell just do a search yeah
hey there you go it's first it's the
number one so here's the th
sean parnell former governor alaska is
actually the card that pops up
but your website is yeah so yeah but so
that's the point so
look candidates there's we already
talked about like there's a direct
correlation be
between your ability to raise money as a
candidate and getting your message out
the republican party
they don't give you money you know like
it's all about your ability to raise
money now
you want to talk about big tech having
their finger on the thumb or on their
finger their finger on the scale
uh tipping tipping the scale in one
direction now
google any other candidate in the state
of pennsylvania who are you who would
you be running against on i mean there's
it's just google google a guy named john
fetterman the uh lieutenant governor
i got him yeah just google him see if
his website comes up on google first
thing
first thing is his twitter and then
governor.pa.gov then johnfetterman.com
that okay there you go
so if you're on google the primary
mechanism that everybody
in this and he's running for the senate
and he's running for the senate so my
opponent right now
has or or a potential opponent right now
this is a primary right there's a
primary right there's a republican
primary
but my point is they have a distinct
advantage right now and this is this is
big tech
i'm telling you it says big tech putting
they're putting their thumb on the scale
helping one side over the other so yes
there needs to be reform and by the way
this hinders my ability to to to
raise money and get my message out so to
t hey
smash smash my win red link and
contribute to my campaign because
you can't find my you can't find it on
the website and i'm gonna need all the
help i can get in the senate race in
pennsylvania
you do but i think it might be too late
or uh
so what year was it that alex and milo
and everybody got banned was at 2018
yeah that was that was a couple of years
ago a couple years ago 17 or 18.
paul joseph watson got his instagram
taken down and it was just like selfies
in the sun or whatever
banned from facebook milo alex now
people might not like them but a lot of
people do like them and they were some
of trump's biggest supporters
and it was obvious get rid of the
largest communities where people gather
to support
donald trump and other populist
politicians
and you will beat them and it happened
it happened over and over and over and
it kept happening and i talked about
this because i made a segment
something about republicans are too
stupid to deal with censorship to save
their own careers
and here we go now they're they're not
going to win they're going to win where
it's deep
red but i mean i will say surprisingly
the polling was was tremendously
favorable to republicans
in the in the 2020 election for sure but
right now
with what we're seeing out of you know
pennsylvania for instance philadelphia
specifically
30 lead for the progressive
all right i don't think we're going to
see a republican you know huge turnout
in the general because it's just
it's a city philadelphia philadelphia is
tough but i will tell you like in the
look this is what i mean like this is
what i mean about going to certain
places the first week of the campaign
i went into south philly i went to the
italian market and i talked to business
owners there
showing up matters it doesn't mean
you're going to get it doesn't mean
you're going to get a majority of the
vote
but you've got to show up for people
right and you know i've been on this
show with you
four times it's not like i'm a i'm a
crazy right-wing bomb thrower truthfully
i'm a consensus builder i'm i consider
myself a leader right
you know when i was in afghanistan i led
the most diverse platoon you could
possibly imagine
rich next to poor black next to white
christians next to atheists next to
muslims democrats next to republicans
next to socialists
you know we figured out a way to make it
work in one of the most hostile regions
on the planet because we figured out a
way to look past our many differences as
americans
and unite under a common banner and
fight for a common mission if i can do
that in afghanistan or a remote hilltop
and one of the most hostile regions on
the planet we sure as i can do it here
in the country
that's my message everywhere yet you
can't find me
on google that's a problem it's a real
problem do you know when the republican
primary is going to be
it for senate yeah it's a year it's a
year so that may
if in case you're wondering yes that's a
long time yes i just threw up in my
mouth a little bit but the problem is is
and i do think campaigns generally last
way too long but
we've already got candidates in the race
raising a ton of money especially on the
democrat side
and if we wait to get in you could find
yourself in a 10 million dollar hole and
that's impossible to dig yourself
out you know so um yeah i mean i suppose
there's some optimism in that uh the
democrats have a very very slim
control right now and they've gone back
to sleep and ratings are in the gutter
because
you're absolutely don't pay attention
anymore look 2022 is going to be look
we talked about the the ballot questions
that
should give you a little inkling about
where public sentiment
is with regards to these lockdowns for
example or
or control which is the really a core
core
pillar of the camp of democrats or
radical democrats
um and so i think 2022 is going to be a
great year
uh for for republicans conservatives
leaders uh in pennsylvania pennsylvania
is
absolutely winnable absolutely winnable
uh i i personally think we're going to
win pennsylvania
so who are the senators right now for
pennsylvania uh senator pat
toomey who's his seat's being vacated
right so he's a republican
and so there's an open seat right it's
an open seat so you wouldn't be
campaigning against an incumbent you've
got an open seat the first time there's
an open seat in pennsylvania in a very
long time
you've got senator bob casey who is a
democrat and
he's been there uh for a couple times
are they both up for re-election or
it's this uh just the op yes
yes so this is an open seat right so a
republican is retiring
um and so yes biggest
senate race in the country so if this
goes democrat
you lose control of the senate it's
already you know the tiebreaker goes to
the democrats because of kamala harris
so
we ha this the senate seat in
pennsylvania is a must hold seat
it's it's a must hold it it is because
of
mansion mansion is the west virginia
democrat whose
democrat and the democrats are outraged
because they call him like the guy the
gatekeeper the key holder that's right
if you lose pennsylvania and it goes
democrat
mansions out doesn't matter anymore now
the republicans and the democrats win
you're 100 correct and and i mean
christian sienna
senator sienna right out of arizona is
sort of holding the line with senator
manchin as well
right but without pennsylvania without
pennsylvania the path to
the majority is through arizona right
against against senator kelly
a democrat or in new hampshire right
um pennsylvania that's why that's why my
campaign motto is when pennsylvania save
america
because we we are the true hedge against
the radicalism of the
new progressive left this is 2022 this
is 2022.
so it's also possible that republicans
take back the house which
even 538 right now is saying republicans
are likely going to win back the house
i'm not entirely confident unless we
start seeing some actual populists
you know run and win a many win uh many
of these seats
because if we just get more you know
establishment types like chinese or
kinzinger's then just
canada candidates matter candidates
matter a lot and
it's not just about i cannot if you're
out there and you're thinking of running
for office whether it's local state
federal it's not just about your ability
to articulate a message
okay it's about your ability to
fundraise and it is not easy
right fundraising means that you're on
like people
think that me running a campaign first
of all is like on stage with trump
like at a rally in front of 50 000
people and yeah that happens and yeah
that was a
it was an unbelievable experience to be
a part of that but that's one percent of
it
it's like five hours a day on the phone
calling people cold calling people have
you ever done sales calls try cold
calling people and just and say hey
you know and then asking for like 2900
bucks see how often you get hung up on
see how often people tell you no but you
have to be relentless with it and
what i see is that all too often
candidates aren't willing to do that
and but but you got to do it you know
one of the biggest challenges for
republicans is
when you're dealing with a message of
we're going to give you free stuff
versus be responsible for yourself and
go work hard
i think i know where people are going to
lean towards i don't know about that tim
i don't know
i i i know that i know that like and
i'll tell you talking to business owners
like one of the main
issues that they're facing right now and
whether it's in the restaurant industry
in the manufacturing sector or whatever
is that we're paying people more uh to
stay home on unemployment than go to
work that's a problem right
and people are choosing to do it yeah
well that's right i mean well look if
you're
if you're if you're a a mother of three
you've got three little kids and you
have an opportunity to stay home with
your kids for for a few weeks and and
spend time with them you're gonna take
that and i'm not gonna fault you
right um well the gop tweeted you see
that thing they tweeted what did they
say that you know
more women are choosing to stay at home
and with their children than go to work
and
all of these like twitter conservatives
were like what is wrong with you i don't
know i don't pay i
look i'm focused on winning the senate
in pennsylvania in 2022 i don't i can't
speak to any of that but like
our job as as leaders i think you know
and and
part of my core philosophy is
you know my personal mission is to go to
go to washington when we win do
everything
that i can to shrink the size and scope
of the federal government
because i think that too much
consolidated power in washington i
believe that there's a direct
correlation between that consolidated
power
and less freedom in our lives right and
so
we can shrink the size and scope of the
federal government we can divert as much
power back to the states as humanly
possible because ultimately the states
are the experts every state like
states or the they know what they need
right uh and so
more freedom in our lives is a good
thing and then when i'm done with that i
mean i'm not a career politician you're
not going to see me in washington for 40
years but you bet after a couple terms
i'm going to
get myself a farm in western
pennsylvania and probably never talk to
anybody again but
but but yeah i know i know you do but
but the point is
is that i i think by and large it's our
job to advocate
for things like pro pro growth policies
right like
low taxes letting people keep more of
their own money rolling back regulations
to make sure that pennsylvania is a
place where people can start a business
and not feel like it's too onerous of a
process right
protecting the energy industry
understanding that there are a couple
different pillars underneath that issue
one of which is the economic issue
people paying more for gas right now
than they probably should more to heat
their homes
that economic issue disproportionately
affects middle income to lower income
families like we don't want that right
we want those families to be lifted up
and keep more of their money so
to the extent that we can be energy
independent it's good for middle middle
class lower income people but there's
also significant national security
implications for it you look at what's
happening now
right joe biden cancels the keystone xl
pipeline puts 10 000 plus union workers
out of work
hurts our energy independence all with a
stroke of a pen
while approving and rolling back
sanctions on russia
to to approve their pipeline so so joe
biden is literally creating jobs in
russia
helping their energy independ
independents helping the russian economy
to allow them to export natural gas all
around the world
while all while they're on the border of
ukraine if imagine though listen imagine
if
president trump did that they would be
calling him a russian asset
well they already were but you know oh
of course they already were but but yes
this proves it yeah this proves it but
you see my point right and so
uh energy independence is something
that's important it's a major pillar of
the economy
in pennsylvania and healthcare is a big
deal right
the gop has not had a good answer on
health care
for a long time and i think you know
part of my
platform is having a good market-based
innovative plan for health care like we
all talk about the republican talking
points of letting insurance companies
compete across state lines more
flexibility
more choice means lower cost for the
consumer and and a more diverse
health care plan offering all of that's
great uh in talking about association
healthcare plans of the idea of small
businesses being able to band together
to have the same purchasing power
as large corporations that's good right
but what if we like think outside the
box for a second
and take things a step further and say
why don't we let individuals
of a similar age sex demographic
with similar health care needs
individuals band together on app-based
technology
it essentially becomes an insurance pool
you have millions of people on
you can call it a platinum plan gold
plan silver plan whatever
but people that like 25 year olds have
similar health care needs right like
it's not perfect right but you can
invest money you pay a certain amount of
money on a monthly fee for a healthcare
app you become a member of that
healthcare plan
and and you allow individuals now to
have the same purchasing powers large
corporations republicans need to
need to start thinking outside the box
on on having
good pragmatics policy solutions
to make our lives better it's true but
you go to a regular person and say
they want you to come up with some plan
for banding together we're just going to
give you free stuff
well the problem is is that you know
first of all it's not
it's not virtuous to take someone else's
money
tax someone else and give their money to
someone there's a lot of people who
don't care
well just give me the free stuff i don't
care they will care because
the problem is is eventually you run out
of other people's money and then
the democrats come out and blame the
republicans saying it's your fault for
not raising the debt ceiling or whatever
and so you look at what's going on with
these police and they defund the police
there's then no cops to deal with crime
and they say see look the cops aren't
even doing anything anyway
they use the problem they create to then
advocate for
more destruction of the system well that
you can't just be like free healthcare
which is what they keep saying and
regular people who don't know
are like i'll vote for that and they're
like okay how do we do it well you can't
so let's just fake it till you make it
so they're like print more money i guess
i think aoc actually said deficit spend
oh right just basically you're just
talking about stripping away the
the value of the working class from
their savings to fund
health care yeah it's it's distribution
well it's not
even just health care if you're looking
at like so joe biden i think in his
first hundred days of as president and
infused something like two and a half
trillion dollars of cash into the
economy
and what you're seeing is not just a
lackluster jobs report i think they they
expected
you know close to a million jobs they
got two hundred fifty thousand is
absolutely horrible right so there was
that
in addition to inflation just this month
four point two percent right
now inflation means the dollar has
individuals have less purchasing power
their dollar is worth less it's
basically
inflation is a tax on everybody and
again
it disproportionately affects middle to
lower income people when you want to
look at inflation you see
inflation reflected in the cost of our
commodities like try to go
and buy lumber to build a deck on your
house and you're gonna spend
probably five six times as much on that
wood
right so i i inflation is not just on
our doorstep it's here
you know joe biden for all he talks
about no he's not going to tax people
that make less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
first of all i i wouldn't believe that
he's going to
okay uh but inflation is a tax
on the middle class attack it's on on
middle-income families right
um not being energy independent
essentially
is a tax on the middle income and lower
income families so
what the point that i'm building to here
is that it's our job as leaders
uh in the republican party to have
policies and be able to specifically
articulate those policies that advocate
for pro-growth positions and they can't
just be talking points
you have to talk about why it's
important to make you know to advocate
for policies to make pennsylvania
prosperous right
let's talk about policies that uh we
don't want we have this
story from the daily mail exclusive it's
become an
outdoor psychiatric ward how
california's scenic venice beach has
become a homeless hot spot with tent
cities
violent crime and rampant drug use
pushing families and tourists out
i'm not even sure i can show any of the
photos because you might get in trouble
on here
but you can see that for a lot of
reasons it's just be
wow wow wow wow that's all i can say i
was i was in venice only a few years ago
i skated the skateboard there all the
time you got these before and after 2015
and 2021.
you swipe across tent cities
something doesn't work in california
their policies are just a disaster
and it's it's unfortunate because you
know northern california is very
different from the big cities in
california
and when most people talk about
california they're not talking about the
you know the farming territories and the
you know counties in the east they're
talking about la and san francisco maybe
sacramento the bay area
even san diego's got i think they still
have a republican mayor but their
policies don't work
whatever this is there's a recall now
for gavin newsom
what you see in places like california
will be coming
to many more places in this country if
these policies expand
so if uh pennsylvania ends up going
democrat
they're just going to keep burning the
place down it's going to it's going to
become more and more like this
i mean you're right i mean california
has been under
a uniparty rule democrat rule for how
long now 30 40
50 years i mean something is republican
before like what 1991 or 92
yeah yeah and so i i yeah i i think that
there there is a direct correlation
between
you know this new new progressive
democrat views
and entrenched poverty in places like
california and drug use
and high crime right and people keep
voting for it
i mean in some places
in some places you know i think
pennsylvania is one of those places that
you know in 2022 you know pennsylvania
has a lot of independents that i think
are going to have buyer's remorse that
that
perhaps believed joe biden uh was a
moderate not their fault the media
portrayed him as a moderate
uh and big tech censored stories that
were negative about them and so you saw
that poll of like
you know how what percentage of people
would have voted differently had they
known the hundred bucks i mean that that
that alone like an average of what six
percent
six percent or seven percent of people
yeah would not have voted for joe biden
now they know that story
and and like big tech totally censored
it
they they censored one of the one of the
oldest newspapers in the country so it's
not like it was like
it was it was a newspaper that they
censored so
so i yeah i i think that that it but i
think that
there's going to be a lot of
independence and i think there's even
going to be some moderate democrats
saying
whoa this is not what i bargained for
and so
you you know me i'm an idealist when it
comes to this country
uh i think it it can be saved um
with the right candidates with the right
message and the ability to articulate
and willingness to go to the places
uh where you need to build bridges you
know and that's what we're trying to do
in pennsylvania what's your history like
politically what
what did you affiliate as in your 20s
and i've always been i've always been
conservative
you know i don't know have you ever seen
that movie legends of the fall no only
clips
everyone on the show is like what
parnell watched legends of the fall
yeah i watched it once when i when i was
younger but like i i have a lot of
i i have a lot of libertarian uh
libertarian
uh uh you know friends
i mean i i don't i i don't
i don't like the government i don't
think that they run things efficiently
and if you don't believe me like
let me think of an example like cash for
clunkers remember that like they come
with an awesome program right they ran
out of cash in a month the government
does not remember
the obama the obamacare website remember
when obama gave all those guns to the
cartels
yeah i don't oh and can i can i also say
something
you know you know classic classical
liberalism right
after the vietnam wars really i think
was when it was born was all
based on critical thinking and mistrust
of the government right
classical liberalism is like what found
in this country well sure
sure sure of course of course of course
but
in the wake of in the wake of the
vietnam war like if the government told
you
to eat white bread you know most
liberals were like no i'm eating wheat
bread just because the government told
you but
somewhere but somewhere along the way
there's been a shift on the left from
the sort of classical liberalism and
tolerance uh uh and diverse set of
ideals to
believing everything the government says
hook line and center with no critical
thinking
just you gotta not be a conservative
that's it
so even now when fauci is like you can
take off your mask if you vaccinated
they're like no
no because then people will think i'm a
conservative
who cares what is that their whole
identity is built upon hating somebody
that's it
it's like what are your politics i just
hate that guy is that it that's right
that's that's part of the reason why
that's part of the reason why you know i
i think it's very important to be a
happy warrior right because
you know as if you're running a campaign
you know one of the things you have to
do
is draw a contrast right give people a
choice right and i think one of the ways
i think the radical left today's day and
age
they're pretty unhappy they're unhappy
and they i feel like they're unhappy a
lot but and
i'll tell you this in the past year two
years we have seen
the biggest de-radicalization of the
left
that we've probably ever seen in this
country i'm pretty impressed so a lot of
people i knew from occupy wall street
the anti-fa far leftists
they're cheering for major
pharmaceutical companies they're
cheering for the fbi and the government
and i'm like i see their posts i'm not
kidding like antifa types
saying like yay fbi you go get giuliani
and i'm like
i'm glad to see that you've reformed
your ways and you're pro federal
government
and they're like well i mean it's
different now cause they're going to
people i like and i'm like yeah
so you like the fbi right like that
that's cool i remember when you thought
they were bad and wanted to like you
know
you hated the government they were
protesting all the time now you're now
you're cheering for the government
now you're cheering for the massive
multinational massive multinational
pharmaceutical company so
hey good for you you know i thought you
were kind of off the deep end they don't
they don't they don't seem to
self-reflect 10 years ago they're like
monsanto bad these big pharmaceutical
companies are evil now they're like yay
which team
are you on yeah well um
i you know yeah i think that's why
the republican party ha they they've got
a tremendous opportunity
right i just i think that you know gosh
president trump uh he he brought about
a a massive shift in the republican
party especially in pennsylvania right
where in in the span of four years
the republican party has has become less
the part i mean
in fact probably not at all at this
point the party of large corporations
to the party of the working man and and
woman
like the shift is like unbelievable the
democrats are the party of the elites
and the college professors and the
hollywood people and the highest
income earners in the country have been
demanding for four years
the working class pay off all of their
debts yes and we're to the point now
where elizabeth warren bernie sanders
have entertained
stripping the value from the
working-class savings to pay off the
debts of the highest investors in the
country
i want you i want everyone to think
about that for two seconds bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren
were in favor of stripping the savings
devaluing the savings
of the working class to pay off the
highest income earners debts that's
absolutely correct that's college
degrees
yes people who with college degrees make
substantially more than people without
it
and those people are demanding the poor
pay their bills for them
i mean i'm not all about that that's
wrong that is wrong
and that that's you're 100 correct how
was how was how have the conservatives
moved like they appear to be even lefter
than many of the modern democrats like
no no joke
you've got the the the trump supporters
many are working class union guys who
want their factories back
and then you've got the the the
university leftists
with their degrees and their hillary
clinton and their hedge funds and their
super pacs
and then you you see the uh the neocons
lincoln project people joining the
democrats how is it that republi
republicans
are are left of the establishment
democrats they're defending the workers
rights
not the democrats the democrats are
stripping away their rights stripping
away the value
value giving money to the bourgeoisie
look that
i think the republican party has to
embrace this this new identity this new
working-class identity these these are
our people these are the people that
built this country right and i think
that we have to
i think that we've got to be there for
them we can't shun them i mean
i mean jim banks had a memo if you've
seen jim banks's memo the working-class
memo that
and and and basically it's is uh
congressman
banks is is i think he's he's great uh
but he's got a memo out there about the
path forward for the republican party
and it's like a
it's like a two-page plan of what the
republican party needs to do to be
successful
it's awesome and we should totally
embrace it you should google it right
now and have a look at it but it's it's
something that we should definitely
look it's a showing up for the people
just uh
here's what you do you just uh write
down what ron desantis does
and then just be like what he said he's
coming to pittsburgh tomorrow oh i'm
gonna go with him tomorrow yeah
excellent he's coming to our lincoln
he's doing a fantastic job he's far from
perfect so
look he's balanced he's balanced you
know
protecting people from a global pandemic
with
people's freedom right and he's done
social media censorship
and social media censorship yeah he's
done a
a pretty darn good job you know their
concerns about what people uh people
question
conservatives his stance on free speech
issues like
he may be opposed to the censorship but
it's aimed mostly at
affecting politicians and then there are
some issues around people's right to
free speech i think relating to israel
that people are concerned about but i
look at you know you i i don't just see
like one thing and say flush the baby
out the bathwater i'm like
ron desantis is doing it pretty well
texas is doing pretty well uh
too their their social media bill
apparently is is much much better
and we need to see we need to see more
red states
start having this aggressive legislation
to go after these companies and these
things because i'll tell you
florida has this bill that's that's i
believe i believe that descendants may
have already signed it is about to sign
it
which gives protections to individuals
companies news organizations and
politicians when it comes to censorship
however facebook as ian points out could
be like then we're cutting off florida
and if you have a florida ip you can't
access the service anymore sure
then what happens in west virginia
tennessee texas arkansas mississippi
georgia
they all start lining up with the exact
same legislation okay then facebook only
exists in new york and california how
about that no they wouldn't want that
that would destroy the company so they
would say okay fine you win
we'll stop censoring conservatives you
know
one of the biggest problems that i have
with politics right now
is that i mentioned conservatives many
republicans seem to be more concerned
about the opinion of the new york times
than their constituents like they're
more worried than your time they'll say
about them than their own constituents
yeah you you look at what the media says
and they lie every single day they say
there is no bias against conservatives
and i'm like but
you're the one it was gizmodo that broke
the first story one of the first
that facebook was censoring conservative
news outlets now they changed their tune
because they realized
it's a good thing these these
journalists who first reported it were
like oh look what i found
then they were like no no no we like
that they're censoring these ideas
because then
people can't have them if they don't
share the ideas they won't know so keep
them ignorant keep them in the dark
dream like mushrooms you know you feed
them crap and you keep in the dark so
now you're gonna start seeing a lot of
states hopefully
start picking this up i'm stoked when i
look at the past 10 years and i see how
many states have adopted constitutional
carry
fantastic it's remarkable i didn't even
realize that in the 80s
you couldn't even get a concealed carry
permit in most states it was like may
issue they tell you to screw off
now it's constitutional carry you walk
in you pass a background check
you walk out with a gun and you can be
carrying it concealing it whatever
fantastic protecting people's rights
let's see the same thing across the
board at the state level
the states need to start passing these
laws local is where it's at yeah
yes yes i would also say that i think
it's it's very
the the states that do the best have
a great communication between their
federal office holders the governor
and the state legislatures right so i
think yes yes i think
a governor can have an unbelievable
power if he's got a legislature that's
willing to work with him they can get a
lot of things done and bring about
profound positive change
in in people's lives i think you take
that to the next level
where you've got a governor that's
communicating seamlessly with
like a senator congress congressmen or
women uh and and everything is is
working like a smoothly oiled machine
that's how you do it and that that's
really what we're we're trying to do in
pennsylvania with regards to uniting
the republican party both in washington
dc
as a liaison as a candidate for senate
as a liaison to the federal government
but also working hand in glove with
those state representatives who are
boots on the ground
in their communities every day and
making sure our messaging is on point
our organizing is on point our
fundraising is on point and we're
advocating for policies that are the
best for
all of pennsylvania at every level right
i'm concerned that
uh just the fragmentation of the u.s is
getting too severe
you know when you look at these cities
they got rising crime they have ongoing
riots
and they just for whatever reason you
get more far leftists in
and then i can only imagine that in the
red areas people are
are separating each other you know like
how many people have moved to texas
recently
tons of personalities that are
conservative are fleeing to texas
so tax is going to become increasingly
more red the blue areas will become
increasingly more blue and then there's
going to be
no real overlap i think so i think
there's some people that would say that
there are leftists moving from
california to texas
and that's why people are worried about
texas turning blue right there's this
whole texas turning blue movement
so that's why people are leaving people
were leaving
states where they voted in democrat
democrat leadership for 30 years and
then going and essentially voting the
same way
in in texas and and i don't think texas
is going to is going to turn blue but
people always talk about it
i think now it won't because people who
are fleeing texas are conservative
or at least opposed the democrats they
saw a huge rise in homeless
in austin certainly i mean it might just
be everywhere
in all these metropolitan problem cities
but evictions are starting up i think in
two months because the moratorium was
ended
in texas everywhere so we we're on the
verge of looking at like millions upon
millions of evictions
they said on sixth street in austin it's
just like tent city
and in california not just in venice in
california in la there's i'll tell you
up and down you know i heard something
scary what streets
it's a video rumor going around that the
u.s government is threatening subsidies
of farmers
so there's a thing i think it's called
fallowing where they're basically paid
not to grow food
yeah and so there's a concern right now
that because of the shortages and
everything's happening and the
how the tax subsidies work that we have
like we're like eight months out from
some serious food shortages
i wouldn't be surprised the the idea
that you can just
stop an economy dead in its tracks and
then snap your fingers and get it back
going again no
the workers are displaced what would be
the end state for that like how could
that possibly be a good thing like i
haven't heard no i'm not saying i'm not
saying it's a good thing i'm not saying
anybody wants to do it
i'm saying that why would the federal
government want to do it the system by
which we have
subsidies for farmers has created a
circumstance based on having that's
happened
which is contributing to gotcha the
probability of more so there's already
food shortages
about people i guess you're not seeing
at the national you're not seeing in
national news but if you look at these
local news outlets they're talking about
food shortages
now there's rumors that the supply chain
disruption
the rising fuel costs have made
everything substantially harder
workers are displaced because of the
pandemic many moved they're not going to
go back to those jobs
right people don't realize that the
shortage we're seeing for like computer
chips
what do you think is going to happen
with food like do you think that food is
immune from the shortages we're
experiencing the economy
no no and no in fact it's the the supply
the logistics chain is is real
right you look at the look look at the
cost of of food and
and how much people are paying for
certain things it's it's
it is absolutely concerning and my my
fear
is that you know because i mean we're
seeing inflation now
you know i think i think that i think
the federal government
like they're not going to hard default
on on our on our debt right i do think
they're going to print their way our
debt and deficit issues are the biggest
the greatest leadership challenge that
my generation of leaders
are going to face right it's a big deal
we've got to figure out what to do with
our debt and deficit but
you know we're not going to hard default
on our debt but i do think what what the
plan
is is is a soft default which is to
purposefully inflate our currency so
that the value of our debt
is worth less right and and and
i think that's what you're seeing right
now and i think that's what you're
talking to right now and
my fear is that we are on the brink of
now i mean
we're on the brink of what could be a
recession
i think a year from now you know um
and and and hopefully hopefully we can
pull ourselves out of it but
like we really have to start advocating
for both economic policies like
right away we really have to start i
don't know what i don't i don't know how
you fix this man
the the train it's a freight train on
the tracks and then they just stopped it
and then all the carts flew up in the
air from the inertia and just scattered
all over
and now they're like all right set the
train up again and you're like bro one
cart like rolled down the mountain it's
in the ocean i don't even know how to
get that back up here yeah so
when when they shut down the economy and
that this idea that you could just start
it up again
was is ludicrous let's say you've got 10
employees making 16 bucks an hour at a
restaurant
economy shuts down these people who are
in their early 20s decide to move back
home they go to the suburbs to stay with
their parents
okay start the economy back up
restaurant goes we don't have any
employees
we have to rehire everybody to start
without any money food all spoiled
you can't just do it we just spent an
entire week going all across the state
talking to business owners from erie
down to south philly and they've all had
that problem
it is not imaginary and and nobody wants
to work when you get paid more not to
work
yeah and you're right like they're
having issues uh both in shipping and
logistics and food processing
and finding finding truck drivers and
the cost of fuel has made it more
difficult on truck drivers to get from
point a to point b
i mean there there are issues at every
level i mean again i think you can i
think it can be saved
but it's going to take leadership and
focus
and clear clear communication
clear honest communication with the
american people which you know
uh is not uh joe biden's strong suit um
so you know look that's that's why it's
so important that's why it's so
important to win in 2022 that's why the
slogan
is when pennsylvania save america i want
to bring up a story we have here this is
really cool
and uh i was i was so i saw this story
over at daily mail it's body cam
captures moment cop
single-handedly lifts over turned car
off virginia mother thrown outside
vehicle after crash
and first of all i was like dude that is
cool
a cop to save a woman lifted the vehicle
by himself
amazing wow now i think it was upside
down and he like was able to push it off
and roll it or something
but i was also thinking like you rarely
see these stories go viral
exactly i was just sitting here thinking
the same thing it's it's you know you
got all of this anti-police rhetoric
every single day which is of course why
you're seeing
uh a violent crime rise in in a city
like philadelphia
it's it's and you talk about like
removing a cop's qualified immunity like
give give your viewers an example of
what that means like as a soldier on the
battlefield you've got protection in
that regard too so in other words if one
of my soldiers gets injured i run out
and i try to
you know give for render first aid maybe
they got a sucking chest wound and i
we we saved their life put them on a
helicopter get them back to the states
and maybe they have an issue with their
lungs
right like should that soldier be able
to sue the
the federal government or the department
of defense because he was wounded on the
battlefield right now
it's illegal you can't do that because
at the end of the day like
you're in combat like you're surrounded
by death and destruction like you're
doing the best you can so the government
is immune from
the dod or or or the army in general so
what does this mean for the cop
well the cop what it means for the cop
is is that you know if a cop is
out there like just trying to do their
job and they can be sued by
they can be sued by anybody for doing
anything 800
absolutely so it's like defunding and
you're 100 right it's like defunding the
police without actually
right they're all it's all about yes i
think
that one's a challenge because i'm not
entirely sure you know how you deal with
it
just not being able to sue maybe there
should be a higher burden or something
because
when we had i think chauvin they said he
had you know like 19 complaints or
something out of 18 years and i'm like
actually sounds pretty good you'd think
a cop is like i'm writing a ticket i'm
going to complain about you
it's like everyone's going to complain
nobody wants to get pulled over nobody
wants to get arrested the point the
point
what we're talking about though is like
to your point is like all we hear is the
negative
but cops i they are out there every
single day putting it all on the line
doing good things for people and this
story is just
one example of it it's a cool story let
me show a little bit
so this is a vehicle flipped over and
the officer was able to lift it up to
save
the individual i mean i'll just give you
the the bull points here they say
gloucester county sheriff deputy john
holt rescued the woman when she had been
trapped under the sunroof of the car
after it wrecked on may 7th
her young son is heard desperately
crying out mommy mommy before the deputy
was able to rescue her
the incredible video has since gone
viral after being shared
on tuesday by the sheriff's office with
more than 84 000 views on facebook
that's not viral 84 000 views not viral
you can you can you can go on twitter
and there's a video of some random dude
farting it's got a million views don't
talk about viral
they say he recently received a local
and regional top cop award
for saving a disabled young girl and a
woman from a burning home last march
but i i still see this and i'm like i've
heard these stories about how people can
can muster up in human strength because
humans are actually much stronger
than we we are on a daily basis there's
i don't know as i thought it works but i
read there's like a limiter
that humans only exert around 20 percent
of their actual muscular capacity
how do you know this stuff as i'm on
reddit
because someone posted like did you use
this i'm just like i don't know if it's
true you gotta you gotta affect me on
this one
but it's something like we have we
there's a limit to how much strength we
can use
unless we get our adrenaline pumping and
there's a live or die moment
because your muscles start destroying
themselves when you exert too much
but what you hear these stories about
like a mother and she's able to like
pull her daughter up like hanging from
with one arm and lift them up and then
pull herself up to save a child or like
lift a vehicle
these are cool stories and so i want to
make sure like we're not always just
just stewing in the negativity but
there's some there's still some
negativity here
what happens on facebook i saw a video
go
going viral today and it was like it was
on reddit and it was like
uh cop kicks a man in the head even
though he's already
subdued and is being arrested and it was
true there's a video of a guy's on the
ground his hands behind his back the
cops cuffing him and a cop runs up and
just punts his head
and i'm like now why would that cop do
that more importantly
i've seen this video a thousand times
because it gets recycled
they put it up it gets traffic they put
it up again this story eighty four
thousand views a cop lifted a vehicle
save a woman
how many times is that going to get
recycled it's not it only got 84 000
views
i see this video on reddit it's got a
million views in a week you'll have a
million views again in a month i'll have
a million views again because they keep
sharing the same things over and over
and over
the social media companies in search
engines control
what you see and when you control the
flow of information
you control what people think in in
certain regards and now people hate the
police
i mean look you look at the algorithms
and what they've produced over the past
10 years it sounds like jack dorsey and
mark zuckerberg purposefully want to
destroy this country
they have driven people insane they
they there are people who literally
believe the cops go around hunting black
people
they they actually believe that so
prageru they send out will wit will goes
to like venice skate park
in california you know same skateboard
we're talking about just a moment ago
and he asked three young black men how
many unarmed black men do they think had
been killed in the past year and they're
like thousands
like it's like 19. it's bad like 19
people but we're in a country of 320
million people was it 375 million police
interactions
19 of which resulted in unarmed black
men being shot and killed
and of those some of them are actually
justified
in like a guy was trying to run someone
over so he's not armed but
he's using a car or they're about to
attack someone or
they're about to like they grab someone
by the throat and they're beating them
or pummeling them
or sometimes it's it was it was a it was
a wrongful you know shooting
in in some circumstances they're all bad
we don't want people to die of course
not right but because of social media
because they weaponize this stuff
everyone goes insane and don't get me
wrong
it goes the other direction too what you
see on the left today
is i think social media has has helped
form the culture war into fact in a
faction into factions of
people who blindly just believe whatever
the media says no matter what
and the people who for the most part
distrust the media with
with a decent portion who distrust no
matter what the media says they'll
distrust them
so you end up with people who believe
the earth is flat or who believe in
these weird
conspiracy theories about lizard people
because they go online and they can find
the stuff and they believe it
and i hear some of the craziest stuff
when i when i read when i read the news
but do those people have any
institutional power the people who think
the earth is flat are they in congress
no well people believe in god i mean
that's almost as ridiculous
no absolutely not there's zero evidence
ever
i mean you want you're gonna ignite a
whole other conversation
it is it's a big conversation but
there's not zero evidence
the issue is if you don't talk about
theism and like religious text and
doctrine i'm not talking about that
um so i'm talking about people you could
literally you could literally climb a
tower and measure the the shadows and
calculate the circumference of the
planet
like that dude uh eratosthenes did yes
in one bc because you can disprove the
earth
earth is flat it's different than you
can prove the earth is round
right believing in god and faith-based
things and and and
you know having philosophy is an
entirely different discussion lizard
people
i mean right there there's there's
there's no evidence
lizard people is dramatically different
from believing in god dude but it's
dramatically similar
no it's not yeah there's just no
evidence i'm eggnog i mean
you're you're you're i i don't want to
deviate yeah and derail the conversation
you're you're confusing
philosophical and theological
conversations with text
and and and and fanny fairy tales
there's text about the flat earth that's
where it comes from
yeah but there's no scientific okay yeah
it's not it was before science was
invented
people go online and they watch insane
videos about insane things and they
believe it
they go online and they read books about
you know they see things about critical
race theory it's insane and they believe
it
and that's bad zealotry and
fundamentalism all of these things are
problems
they exist so the problem is we need
critical thinking instead we get
critical theory
and then people just blindly follow and
march off cliffs like lemmings
well and it's it's it's it's it's it's
not just social media right like a
much of the sort of propaganda that is
pushed on people on social media is also
taught in schools and so we're teaching
our kids from a very young age in our
public schools like critical race theory
for example that
you know teaches kids to dislike each
other or
think about each other based on the
color of their skin or or hate their
country
or hate their country or think that
america is
fundamentally evil or bad and this this
is a problem and not only is it
happening in our schools now it's
happening in our military right
like there are there are ideological
purity tests for people the miller
teaching critical race theory in the
middle
in the military and i'm telling you look
i got out i was medically retired
um in 2010 so it wasn't that long ago i
mean we're talking like 11 years ago i
got out
this stuff was nowhere to be found in
the military because
it ain't about you right in the military
one of the things they teach you at
basic is that
it's okay all of this like you know it
ain't about you anymore so we're gonna
shave your head we're gonna put you in a
uniform
we're only as fast this team is only as
fast as its slowest person we're all
gonna make our bed the same way our
lockers are all going to be the same way
because what they're doing there
is creating they're they're whittling
down the individual identity
and they're creating a collective right
and that and look past our differences
work together differ but that but that
that that sounds a bit like what the
critical theorists do
but that's that's not but but see the
the difference is
is that the focus in in critical race
theory is
only on our differences right that's if
that's a fundamental difference
and in the military that can get you
killed because the goal of critical
theory is to destroy
it's to deconstruct yes they genui
i look i i know i've known many of these
people for a long time
and they have routinely expressed their
desires to destroy the system
they just want to watch some say i just
want to watch it burn some say from the
ashes of the old we will build the new
that's the idea so critical theory is
their means to an end they think
they will just they will deconstruct
everything make it impossible to have
communications
they will fracture any ability for a
collective identity within the united
states and
after that it's rubble then they'll come
back with their you know
whatever communism socialism we were
always taught growing up that
the reason why america was such a
wonderful player part of the reason
uh was that we have people from all over
the world that come here
to live the american dream uh be free
give a good life to their kids why
because america is a melting pot do you
remember that do you ever were you ever
taught that as a course the great
american melting pot yes
well america right now it's a melting
pot that's not melting
and that that that's a pretty that's a
problem critical theory is trying to
re-emulsify the differences whereas we
used to believe that you throw everybody
in the melting pot and you get a nice
fondue with a bunch of different flavors
they're actually trying to reverse
entropy to get the pepper jack back out
of the food
compare you just compare america and the
american people to fondue i've never
i've never
said melting pot i've never had fondue
it's good it's a melting pot what is it
it's melted cheese i
talk about derailing the conversation
i'm sorry but but i don't know what's
wrong with this
fondue is it melting pot my diet you get
a little thing
you throw cheddar and you throw in swiss
and pepper jack and whatever
and then you turn it on and it melts all
of the cheeses together and then you dip
stuff in the cheese it sounds like
something that you it sounds like
something that you would like really
like you it's incredible
we got we have one on the counter right
porsche of course you do of course
or you can take like oil some garlic
some vinegar soy sauce
and then boil it and you put the meat in
it you blend everything it's just a pot
fruit this sounds a little adventurous
to me like i
like if you if i go to a restaurant you
give me dino chicken nuggets some tater
tots i am good
here's here's the i eat like a
two-year-old the great american i don't
know how we're here i don't know how we
got it it's a great american
listen great american melting pot right
you get some
some chihuahua cheese from mexico you
get some american cheese from america
you get some
some good uh dubliner from from ireland
i think it's from ireland
and then uh you you you throw it all in
a pot and it all melts together
and we're like this is some great cheese
what is it i just mixed a bunch of stuff
together i do it all the time
i take like colby jack and pepper jack
and swiss and havarti and i just blend
it up and make nachos
and i'm like isn't it amazing that you
can get this great blend of cheeses you
ever have four cheese pizza
what could you what like dizorno yeah
you go you're like i'll take the four
cheeses
now imagine if you're hanging out with
someone and they were like can i take
the ricotta out of this
ricotta out of this pizza and you're
like it's all blended together yeah i
know but
we should remove it yeah at some point
like that's critical theory or i only
want to eat the
i only want to eat that little bit yeah
yeah no uh and the rest is wasted after
after you only
yeah mozzarella supremacy needs to end
our our pizzas should have different
cheeses so get the mozzarella out you're
like but we melted it all together well
in the future let's actually put blocks
so that your pizza is actually
i mean this what you're saying is
accurate i mean they're actually like in
certain colleges they're having
graduation i mean they said dorms this
is
like this is not progressive this this
is like to be a progressive in today's
day and age is actually to be a
regressive
like they're going backwards in time
with this stuff but they love using
language that's why
so i see on twitter they're like oh
right critical race theory is diversity
and
inclusion there's a reason why they say
diversity inclusivity and equity
are you gonna you gotta tell me right
diversity inclusivity and equity
oh oh i see what you did
diversity inclusivity and equity these
are the things that they're they're
calling for they're literally saying die
i don't know why they do that well they
could not do that they do
use they like they do control the left
does
an extraordinary job at controlling the
language
right and uh that's what that's what
we're talking about now like critical
race theory
is is inherently bad for the country as
we mentioned it teaches people to hate
their country but they mask it and
shroud it in
words that sound nice they literally
create
diversity inclusivity and equity
positions
could you imagine someone hiring a
special person a company
and they say this is our our die manager
die
and it's like it's a little it's a
little weird yeah well hopefully they
don't use the acronym or come up with
something different or reshuffle the
words but it's almost like they're
laughing in our faces
you've got why why do these why are
companies hiring diversity officers
what does that mean it doesn't mean
anything double speak it's 1984
right it's it's basically in in
communist china
companies have to have the commun
communist party member in the united
states
they're just getting these companies to
create a a
an an ideological dogmatic
job that makes no sense other than to
indoctrinate the employees
what what i'll say is that you know
specifically in the context of the
military because i've been speaking out
about this but like
diversity is is a it's a good thing like
in my platoon we were very diverse and
because we were very diverse we had a
multitude of ideas that were brought to
the table all the time but
you have to take diversity is is
it's i don't want to say it's it's
meaningless but
it's you have to have unity beyond the
diversity
in order for it all to work diversity is
a result
of empowering individuals with
opportunity the diversity then comes
from that
you can't force i mean if you force
superficial diversity you're gonna end
up with homogeneity i'm a homogeneity
mm-hmm homogeneity that's it yeah
and that's what we're seeing that's why
they call it critical race theory it's
got a term that well it's
critical theory so one of the other
mistakes people make is they say
critical race theory and they cut out
the rest of it it's like no it's
critical theory in general yeah there's
there's critical gender theory there's
critical literature and
critical literature theory and i would
say that true diversity is actually a
huge
strength because it brings people
together you're capitalizing on the
things that make them
different yeah that bring those good
strong components to your team
of course for example in your platoon
that you were leading
you need all these people with different
strengths of course actual diversity is
pivotal
it's great exactly yes but you're
unified right
right you're unified yes we're all
different but that that's part of what
makes america great yes we're all
different but we bring
aspects of our culture that we love and
we're proud of and we integrate into
american society and then we share those
blessings with other people right
like that's what makes this country
great that's why people risk their lives
to come here from cuba and shark
infested waters
they don't come here because they
believe america is is fundamentally evil
they come here because they believe
america is free
and their kids can have a better life
than them but the new the the radical
left
does not believe that they're taking
this country back in the wrong direction
and we have to stop them we have to stop
them
this guy just won by 30 points in
philadelphia in a primary
in a primary yeah but where are the
democrats to be like yo this is bad no
they're going in
i think i think that most of the
leadership i
can't speak for people right but i would
assume that most of the leadership in
the democrat party knows that
uh this ain't good it's not good for
them
they can't do anything about it i hope
not you were talking about uh
how the the left controls language and i
was just looking up who owns
merriam-webster
it's owned which is the dictionary it's
owned by encyclopedia britannica
incorporated which is owned by jacques
safra i don't know who he is but he's a
millionaire brazilian investor from
geneva
huh the senate of syrian lebanese swiss
jewish software banking family
this guy's basically overseeing the
definitions of the words
dictionary.com is woke yeah they just do
yeah they're super woke
so they're like their definitions they
have recursive definitions
which which definition was it uh that
became recursive
was it gender or something yeah
something like that so they
they they ended up um i can't remember
what word was but dictionary.com
created a definition of a word that
included its own word in its definition
which becomes recursive
so it just basically you can't define a
word by itself but they did anyway
because it's wokeness
it's just it's meaningless like we're
we're off we're offloading the
the responsibility of creating the
definition of words to corporations
and an individual that have political
leanings that own the corporations
that's insane how do we create
like a decentralized definition a system
of definitions
there's wiktionary like here's the
problem man
the left is on the assault and the
conservatives are sitting back with
their feet up
no that's right well i mean the or or
just conservatives in general are on the
defensive side
to your point right never going on one
of the one of the number one things
and and this is reflected in polling
right that that
conservative or republican voters want
in a candidate
is someone who's willing to fight and
not back down it's one of the top
issues and you know that's what people
have in me that's for sure
uh but i think it's also again you just
can't back down
you know what i you know what i want i
want a republican candidate who is going
to vow
to create universal uh gun ownership
like like you know open carry no no
universal gun ownership meaning oh just
we're going to mandate it man mandate so
you want the government
to force people to have guns yes i don't
know that i i don't like the government
so here's the issue
the left comes out and says and this is
you know shout out to michael malus
the left comes out and says we want
universal health here
we want the government to ban private
health insurance
take it all away from you and then run
it themselves that's bernie sanders plan
the republicans say no wait don't the
democrats say we want to take all your
guns away the republicans say
no wait don't where's the republican to
say i demand the government buy
everyone a gun right now so how about
not mandatory but the government is
obligated to give every citizen a gun at
the age of 16
you'll go to the department of gun
services you'll fill out the basic
knowledge test the department of gun
services so now we're growing the
government
now there's a new there's a new brand
there's a new branch yes
so it's like it'd be like a dmv called
the dgs you go in
and if you want your free government
issued gun it'd probably be crappy
but you get you get a rifle and a
handgun in a box and a box of ammo for
each
you gotta go you you'll fill out a form
you know basic questions
gun safety then you'll they'll take you
to the range you'll do your standard you
know shooting test
and then they'll hand you your two
weapons and say have a nice day sir
the republicans don't do things like
that and i get it they're like we don't
want more government to do these things
well if the only thing the republicans
are ever going to do is say no wait
don't
then the democrats will keep winning
because the democrats are offering
things to people
this is what i was saying you have to be
able to you have to be able to
articulate
so when republicans will say i want low
taxes and a strong economy but you have
to be able as a candidate to explain to
people why that matters in their life
right you know like we want our economy
to be strong we want there to be jobs
right
like if we want when kids graduate from
school
there's a reason why there's a census de
population decrease in pennsylvania
we're losing a congressional district
it's because people are moving away why
because we don't have the economic
diversity
uh to sustain the jobs that kids would
want to get when they graduate from
school we want that talent here right
and
i got i got an idea for the republican
party is it another gun
department no no no no if you don't want
to expand
government it's simple will the
republicans
repeal the nfa
what what is what do you mean what are
you the national firearms act so it bans
a
whole bunch of guns it assault rifles
have been banned since going back
towards like the 20s when the nfa was
passed suck the fire rifles
can't be owned by civilians not that i
think anybody you know tactically would
want one but
it's very difficult to get you have to
go through like an automatic yeah so
automatic suppressors
or even short belt rifles or having a uh
putting a brace putting it put a stock
on a pistol you can't do these things
the republicans often say no wait don't
well the democrats say gimme gimme gimme
and so okay if the republicans don't
want to
increase the size of government how
about harsh decrease in size of
government
how about repealing federal gun laws
well i mean i would i would not start
there i would start with
the department of education right i
agree
like i i think we start there i would
also then go
to the irs yeah uh the tax code is
longer than the bible and there's not a
single good word in it yeah right so
we need to simplify that simply start
tearing these chunks out thumb
when i say that we need to shrink the
size and scope of the federal government
this is what i mean
right like the education should not be
something that's handled at the federal
level education is
local right every local community is
different and every local community is
uniquely equipped to
handle the education needs of their
communities and their children right
so i would start at the department of
education then i'd move to the irs
and i would just continue down the line
because department of education i agree
with
yes that you don't agree with the irs i
know i do i do
i'm saying starting with the department
of education right starting now starting
with with gun laws is more
bombastic it's more like meant to be
like ah you know we're going to do
something
you want you want you're doing what the
left would do they just go
big right in your face right right no
that capacity yes
but but i'm not so they're restrictive
the the banning of private healthcare i
think is insane if you want private
healthcare you can have it i think a lot
of these companies are bad and they suck
but hey it's your choice right
so that's why i've been like a public
option how about that you want the
government to do it you can pay for that
if you want the private company do you
pay for that
most of these companies i'm sorry most
countries
do not abolish private health insurance
bernie sanders is extremely radical on
this
so i'm like okay what's what's the
what's one of the most radical things a
republican could do in terms of limiting
government giving back people their
rights is repealing laws
just start repealing these ridiculous
laws i mean maybe you should
i think you you've got a platform i
think oh if i had a platform it would be
nuts and i don't think well i think you
have i think
you think you have a you have a platform
i'd be like okay first and foremost uh
weed
legal immediately no more schedule of
any of that stuff
and a full pardon wait of just of just
of
no more schedule of any drugs or just
weed wheat uh
we however in terms of the war on drugs
in general we got to stop all that we
got to figure something out it's not
working
so if if the goal is to get people to
not do drugs we need to do something
radically different now
i would not immediately do like a a
dramatic policy and just like
get rid of all the schedules because you
don't want to
flip the boat over because you've got a
problem with the boat you want to go
through it and take notes of things and
of course come up with a plan
you want to be deliberate you want to be
right exactly and a lot of what we see
from the left is like
overhaul the system now and you're like
i'd rather not burn it down because
we're upset with it
we might have to take our time and it
might be boring and it might suck but
let's
chill a little bit but i would i'm very
much opposed to the war on drugs
uh i think we need uh
the constitution needs to be reaffirmed
dramatically
like the rights of the constitution need
to be we need to we need to sort through
that
someone asked me a question like someone
asked me a question today like if you
get
if if you if you win like
what's the criteria you're going to look
at when confirming judges right if
you're voting to confirm a justice on
the supreme court and and to me it's
uh well for one let's make sure that
whoever that person is
adheres to the constitution and believes
it as it's
written that matters and in many ways
like especially what you saw in the wake
of the 2020 election even with
unilateral changes to election law
unconstitutional changes to election law
like the question is does the
constitution matter
anymore or not if you know it does to me
and you know and you look at this
off-cycle election it wasn't just a da's
race it was judges
right republicans republicans got strong
judge candidates in
every level now because i think we
realize the importance of how
of of of of electing good judges where
we elect judges in pennsylvania which
which uh i got an idea you know what you
know what i would consider doing
running for office as a republican with
some very serious proposals to force the
republican candidate to move
so i'd be alive to move to the right to
move to the right not necessarily to the
right
i i just move in general in different
areas so i don't i don't know if
um legal total decriminalisation
decriminalization of marijuana is a
conservative position
but i think it would force the
republican candidate to adopt a more
modern position
whatever it may be or at least clarify
and stick a stance on it
gun rights i think republicans would
overwhelmingly just outright favor
if i said i want to repeal the overall
majority of federal gun laws
and i want to establish like strict
rights for what it means to keep and
bear arms codified
you can you know like legal legal
concealed carry across the board
i guess you'll run into a problem with
states rights and that but get rid of
the federal laws at least
and then what happens is i just say like
a whole bunch of things where i'm like
i think there's a case to be made for a
federal carry law
but the states have a right to to to
control their
of course to control their own gun laws
but you also you know if
yeah and then if they violate the rights
i do i i do support
a a constitutional carry provision i do
think there's some wisdom
in being able to carry across state
lines and not be thrown in jail for it i
think
federally you can uh they protect you
but the states don't care that's the
problem so that's actually
the limit on the federal government it's
not not all bad i just think it's
it's problematic that you know the atf
can like shoot a lady and kill her kid
and burn down a house with a bunch of
kids in it you know what i mean and then
they celebrate this every year on
twitter yeah those people are kind of
nuts
so uh maybe the left where are they at
they want to abolish the police can we
start with like i don't know like the
atf or something
yes yeah so you know local cops
okay we'll deal with that but they want
to abolish the dhs i'm like okay well
let's let's get the conversation going
what if when you cross state borders you
got a text
that showed you that sent you a link to
all the laws that are different between
this state and the state that you just
came from
because people don't know the difference
in the laws that's a big problem man we
are so
we are solving the problems of the world
right if only people listen to us you
know
if only people were watching this we
see what the people have to say the
super chats if you have not done so
already please help us out with a like
by
tapping that like button very ever ever
so gently easy
and uh is it is greatly appreciated and
share the show if you like it but uh
also go to timcast.com and become a
member we'll have a bonus segment coming
up later tonight let's read
some super chats i'm sorry good sir with
the first pretend i can't read your name
because youtube has blocked it but they
said hey tim and gang
thoughts on youtubers running for office
many say they feel they are making more
of a difference with what they do
but they have the support to get elected
in a way others don't oh
uh maybe i wonder what the with what the
laws are with like let's say i decided
to run for office and actually won
like i could would i be able to do this
i don't think i yeah no i think you
would i mean ted cruz senator cruz has a
podcast
yeah and i wonder but i wonder how much
time
is consumed i mean this is more
effective i mean senator cruz is a
united states senator and he still
manages to do a podcast so i don't know
yeah
but i think you can still i know you
work i know you're like you're three
hours a day i know you were reporting
with like
five to eight hours of research yeah so
i mean
maybe that'd be great i'd be like i i
would i would probably not be allowed
access to any kind of privet information
because i just i'd say i'm not going to
lie to people
yeah you know it's it's it's it's
interesting um you ever see you ever see
or read watchmen
oh yeah of course of course rorschach at
the end
that you know uh vice has basically
tricked the people into ending the cold
war
and rorschach's opinion is no the people
have a right to know what happened
and i agree and then uh but there there
there's i wouldn't say i'm as morally
absolutist
as he is in that position he would
rather let the world destroy itself and
uh
dude's name doctor dr manhattan just
blows him up
it's amazing it's great writing so
rorschach the character says that the
people deserve to know the truth because
it was a false flag attack that unified
you know
so yeah i think that people have a right
to know i don't think
you know you you get like the new york
times saying don't tell people about the
gas shortage because they'll panic
my attitude is that people have a right
to know what's happening well that was
sort of like
dr dr fauci early on in the pandemic
saying don't wear masks right you don't
need exactly
because doing that sporting he was
hoarding it's kind of like military
command you can probably speak to this
like you don't want to
panic the troops so you they're on a
need to know basis
and as the commander-in-chief of the
military you're kind in a similar
position
you don't want to alarm the populace if
you don't need to
yeah i was more libertarian i think
people have right to know i i would say
they're
i i i mean i'm i'm i'm libertarian
as a in some ways as well but not in
this one i
i think that there are national security
issues that
aren't for public consumption they're
just there just are
all right let's read some more we got
lethal blade says hey tim you should
have on
guns and gadgets if you want to talk gun
laws and what is coming down the pipe
and if you want to talk
commie guns and having fun with guns you
should have on brandon herrera aka the
ak guy
he owns and operates an ak factory in
the u.s oh cool
hmm there you go eric uh i'm sorry trash
panda says
tim 2018 you know i think we can have
some sensible gun control tim 2021
free ak-47s for everyone yes
i think that's accurate i love it well
also kudos for the name trash panda
trash panda
eric ace is glad to see sean parnell
back please invite madison kawthorne on
as well
you know what the problem is with
inviting politicians they always say the
same thing
they say i'd love to come on the show
email this person and we'll get it
sorted
and then we email the person and they
just never respond wait a second are you
classifying me as a politician because
you're sitting in my mouth you're
sitting here i'm saying
when we when we hit up politicians
they're always like yes and we want to
come on the show and then they just
they email this person nothing happens
yeah you're actually here you've been
here a lot
a lot yeah i'm not i'm not i'm not
afraid of conversations you know
here's what here's what i understand the
left is if there's
the left weaponizes anything they can
get against you right and if they have
nothing they make things up so you might
as well just get out there
yeah all right evil zombie hamster says
check out 3d printed arms for chickens
chicken city could have chickens with
hulk arms running around oh chicken city
this is your thing now right i've seen
you post on instagram about chicken city
tell me
we're we're going to put we got the
chicken coop outside i saw that little
houses in it
and we're going to put cameras in it and
then people we're going to create a 24 7
live stream of
the chicken city chicken city reminds me
of tube city like in the office where
michael scott makes a tube city for
gerbils
remember that there you go awesome and
so what we're going to what i want to do
and i don't know how we'll do it
i want to create a system where every 50
that comes in in super chats
it causes a qriket dispenser to drop
some crickets oh yeah
and then the chickens run over this is
why business is booming
here at tim cass it's these innovations
the innovative
things you basically what you're doing
is creating a reality tv show for
chicken city
that's right and and they'll have that
and it could be a video it could be hold
on yeah they all have news
they all have names i thought i was the
only one here i was thinking i was
creating pushing it yeah
okay they all have names they do yes
they all have names they do
and we'll create shirts and then people
will join teams
yeah i named them all they all have
names and so we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna
explain the names and like and then
there's gonna be drama and it's gonna be
you know
you'll see them fighting and yeah
vanessa has that character we're going
to do she does yeah we're going to do
like a bachelor thing because we're
going to get a rooster
and then it's going to be like which one
will the rooster choose
all of them because the rooster
yeah oh it'll be good that would be
great we'll give them 3d printed arms
you know
what i wanted to do i was wondering if
like if if
is it possible is it is it the muscle
strength of the chicken
causing it not to be able to fly and if
there was a way we could do
some kind of like carbon fiber mash to
expand their wings and give them like
falcon
yeah like you can give a chicken a
little falcon suit like in the avengers
yeah i think it's their weight would it
also come equipped with little drones
that would be fun maybe we need and
goggles i know we could do
goggles hold on what if we we created a
3d printed harness and we attached
enough balloons to it
to reduce the weight of a chicken so
that you can fly properly oh
just so that is enough so it's flying
you know
pokemon did that with pikachu i know
this because my
my son i think the balloon thing would
work you don't put enough on it to where
it can just drift off and
you know it's gone you just put enough
on to where it's weighted down but it
can jump
like way higher what do you think what
do you think the chicken would do
freak out no i think you would just
float around and like go home
maybe we start with if i drive up to
this place for a podcast and i see
chickens
floating around your house with balloons
i'm out of here going into space
i'm out of here man but i wanna we we
don't want to stress that chicken
i love your show but that would be that
would be like some
silent hill some stuff you know what i
mean i did want to make 3d printed armor
for them though
so they can't be killed by predators yes
like like a spike plate back armor i
thought about like electrical
stimulation to stimulate the muscles so
they could carry the weight but then i
was thinking like you can't be hard on
the chicken
yeah you could do the chickens yeah but
like you guys have put a lot of thought
into how to supercharge these chickens
you're what you're basically doing is
giving super trying to give super
soldier serum or something like that to
a chicken
like an iron yeah like an iron suit for
the chickens yes i'm opening it
i was actually trying to figure out how
to create a flight suit for the for
bucko he's a cat
he needs one so the idea would be that
when he jumps right
they put their feet out and that would
release carbon fiber and mesh wings
and the tail fin so that he would glide
and then he wouldn't be able to fly but
he'd be able to jump and glide and then
land
you know that's like the apex predator
could you imagine
like you're like a you're like a shrew
or something you see a cat and you're
like i'll be all right i'll get up here
and then the cat just glides across and
like lands
you're like what's happening i'm just
terrorizing all the small woodland
creatures
even more than he already does yeah how
would he retract his carbon fiber wings
when his
arms go down yeah they fold back in
because it would be like
on a string that pulls the gears you
ever see those boston dynamic videos
yeah like robot dogs and they're really
super creepy and definitely scary
what you're doing is is like creating
animal cyborgs
yeah that's terrifying yeah that sounds
great i think they'd be into it wouldn't
you wouldn't you be excited if you had a
suit where when you jumped like
batman cape like glided you down if i
had a i mean
yeah if i had a batman suit it would be
amazing so how do you think the cat's
like a real like a real batman suit with
a real utility belt like not something
you buy at a halloween store like it
actually
it has to actually work like you know
batman he jumps off the building and
then you like his
his cape goes rigid and he glides yeah
yeah like how do you memory cloth
right exactly how do you think the cat's
going to feel when he can like the bird
is like
looking at him and then jumps over i
don't know how the cat's going to feel
because the cats can't speak english
he's going to be so excited i guarantee
you that cat is going to look terrified
there's gonna be there's gonna be a
pigeon or something and it's gonna be up
on like the deck
and buckle's gonna walk up to it and
it's gonna jump over to the other deck
and then it's gonna be like i'm all
right and it's just gonna fly across and
it's gonna be like
what is happening the cat's flying it's
like the german blitzkrieg
no one saw it no it's not coming spanish
inquisition those tanks were fast
god you guys you guys you know you went
from a standard podcast just
four i mean four episodes ago to now
creating cyborg chickens and cats oh you
have no idea what's coming
i don't i mean i i don't chicken city is
going to start up as
is pretty normal people are going to
watch a live stream of chickens
and then what we're going to do is i'm
trying to hire a composer to make you
like beats
oh yeah yeah and then eventually we'll
create a channel we'll create a stream
that's lo-fi hip-hop beats to watch
chicken city too
so now when people are like studying or
whatever they're like you know what do
you know what chicken city reminds me of
it reminds me remember remember when
when the left bought for that fake
the left left media bought the fake
story that president trump did nothing
but watch gorilla tv
garlic yeah i mean i i heard that and i
thought like
well that would kind of be a good
channel like i think i would kind of
watch that with just
gorillas fighting yeah like it's like
they totally wrote a story as if it were
real do you remember that no
all right we got we gotta read a couple
more we got a little derailed there all
right sorry
let's see um jordan says happy one
million tim cast irl subscribers tim
and we did just get the gold uh award
just came in the mail today we got to
put it up
oh yeah matthew sage said happily back
and donate to sean parnell
any website etc to help raise money i'm
a state over but we need level-headed
insane politicians all over
uh that means i mean if every one of
your subscribers gave a buck that's a
i mean that's a big deal well
everybody's every subscriber i mean
well not every subscriber watches every
video so that's right that's right yeah
yeah all of everyone never does anything
yeah right yeah so but it's
still it's still a profound impact man
it's still big what's your website
uh parnell for senate dot com right on
perfect
all right matthew heman says sean do you
think we could have another contract
with america that would allow populist
candidates
to focus on certain topics and elections
and goals when elected
i would recommend getting with jack
murphy and billy prempe to develop it
i think that's really smart i think i
think it's really smart
and this remember that jim banks letter
i told you about that's sort of like in
this vein but it just
yeah i think that's a good idea i think
that's a really good idea
that's a good recommendation all right
juan martinez says hi tim following your
lead in making culture
please check my first children's book
tickled by the travel bug on kickstarter
how cute there you go
all right let's see where we at
golan uh golden daz stop says absolutely
loved your podcast with jocko
can't wait to read outlaw platoon oh
thanks so that that you want can i tell
a quick story about that so it's my
podcast with jocko like i've been
listening
jocko is an awesome guy i love him uh so
like he
invited me on a show i was super excited
about it i get out there in
san diego and like i'm like oh god i'm a
little nervous i don't know what this is
going to be like and
and he walks into his podcast i like
walk into victory mma
and it's an awesome place all these
little octagons and everybody there's
like
200 people there rolling around on the
mat and i'm like where's jocko and jocko
walks in
and it's like he's in like it's like an
episode of cheers like everyone's like
hey
jocko he's like pointing at people and
we and we go into this
little room right closet right yeah yes
and and
we did a five and a half hour marathon
podcast where he had outlaw platoon
he had al platoon just like went through
the chapters and all we did
was have a five and a half hour
conversation
about combat leadership and servant
leadership the whole time and i i
i didn't i thought i was going to be
there for my for my fiction books
like i didn't hit but it was all about
outlaw platoon five and a half hours
long and it it was just
i it's it was it was it was awesome it
was awesome that's so cool
he's the best he is he's awesome jt
goldfish says loved your bookshaw and
gave me flashbacks from afghanistan
but i will never vote for you unless you
try to oust romney in utah
[Laughter]
so wait you want me to be you want me to
be a carpetbagger and move to youtube
yeah i guess so mr behavior says love
how shawn said to tim
quote if you've ever seen star trek as
if tim doesn't reference star trek
like every episode lmao i was saying
just that dude
for the audience yeah and here we go can
we can we stop pretending that
star trek is just a monolith there's
many there's many stars there's there's
star trek with captain kirk there's star
trek next generation there's deep space
nine
so right and that's it and then and then
movies after deep space nine it's over
there's no other star treks
everything i guess enterprise is okay
but it doesn't work
stars were tracked dorsey woods says
republicans have been little more than
speed bumps while progressives are
four-wheel drive
every day more ground is lost with
fortified elections
i'm not convinced the battle can be won
anymore fortifying the home front in
case
it's like there's this drastic need to
change the world
that is true so these people that want
to do all these change all these things
are getting like a pass from the media
and the people that are like yo the
system's not as busted as it seems
they're getting kind of steamrolled
it seems but just change for the sake of
change is not the right way to go you
got to know what you're doing and have a
plan it's sustainable
you sure we shouldn't just burn it down
because we're upset with something i
think we shouldn't
yeah and i think i think her concerns i
mean her concerns
about the election are something that i
encounter every day 50
of the people in the state of
pennsylvania have very little faith in
it but what i can tell you
is we know what they did in 2020 right
and we have a plan we
learned a lot of lessons right and and
uh
we're taking those lessons learned we're
moving forward integrating them into
2022
and we're gonna we're gonna we've got a
plan we've got a plan
brandon tom says tim your 1pm piece was
spot on it doesn't matter how much or
how
how little you know about the middle
east conflict it's conflict it's wrong
to go around beating people based on
immutable characteristics
that's what matters so there's a video
where
there's there's a couple videos a van or
cars
full of people with palestinian flags
yell out like who's
who's jewish and when some guys say they
are they are beating the crap out of
them i saw them
there's a video of people in vehicles
waving palestinian flags chasing an
orthodox jew through the streets
horrible
yeah it's insane it's insane and and i
don't see the left coming out and being
like we must stop this no they're just
like
hamas is defending itself i'm like
they're firing the rockets they're the
ones fight
and and they use schools
they use hospitals and they use
buildings that are co-located with the
media because they know that
american media will freak out if god
forbid
you know one of those targets gets hit
and either way they win they get a
propaganda victory
right if god if one of those buildings
becomes collateral
damage uh or they're shielded because
they know that
they won't be attacked there yep right
and so
i mean i would just say to to the
viewers and like i mean imagine like
imagine your city getting hit with
thousands of rockets i mean i
i lived like that for 485 days my base
in afghanistan
got hit with over 4 000 indirect fire
attacks there's nothing worse there's no
more hellish way to live
than wondering if a rocket is going to
land on your head at any moment whether
you're asleep while you're going to the
bathroom or you're eating it's a
horrible way to live and we're trained
to deal with it
there are young kids living living in
israel right now some
like like of of of all walks of life
that have to live like can you imagine
how that lifestyle affects those little
ones it's unacceptable
kev says sean parnell i need that shirt
who makes it and where can i get one
don't say don't remember it as a label
it's it's uh go go to go to a website
it's called verocloth
h-e-r-o yeah and now i'm promoting
another weapon
yeah yeah it's uh like i love these
shirts i think they're in
i'm trying i'm bringing them bro i'm
making them in yes yes
first last says copp was trained by rock
lee to open the eight gates
and if you know what that means then you
are a friend of this show
and now you're all confused yeah i'm
very confused i thought
and here i thought i was a friend of the
show no no
broccoli is from naruto oh is it this is
that
wait this is this anime show naruto
yeah my kid watches this and my oldest
son watches this
and he loves it yeah is it like a thing
is it like good is it
good for while it was running is it
appropriate for kids that are
yeah okay okay because i'm like ethan
you should be watching this podcast
anyways
it's about magic ninjas okay well now
that's actually existing it's actually
cool writing in terms of politics yeah
magic ninjas andrew
my campaign managers mark that down
thumbs up we're gonna watch it later so
the character rock lee can open his
chakra gates to
flood his body with more energy but at
the cost of like causing damage to his
body
yeah so the joke is that the cop opened
the gate so ah so we could lift the car
off the woman
and yeah i see i get it
joseph soylow says charles hoskinson
just mentioned you in his ama
would be an awesome guest to discuss
crypto on your show absolutely
um uh you reached out to him i think i
did if someone would let him know to hit
me up
i will happily coordinate that i would
love to do so he's the he's the guy who
founded cardano yes
and it's so i have four uh cryptos i
have bitcoin ethereum doge and cardano
and i gotta be honest like i can give
you a reason why but when you go on
gemiini it's like those are the four
that are like there they're just like
bye bye bye
it's probably not a complicated thing
i'm just like i don't know i'm gonna buy
whatever's there
no but uh he was a co-founder of theorem
i guess and bitcoin and ethereum are the
only ones i'm like really confident in
but then i look at cardano i'm like this
guy clearly knows what he's doing
and he's got a different approach to it
so i think once that launches up it'll
be
it'll be pretty big we'll see whatever
i don't think dogecoin is going anywhere
to be honest but i'm going to keep my
dogecoin because it's funny
that's right yeah all right let's see
yeti dude says where are the politicians
that respect the constitution
and the law of the land and restore the
freedom of the people of these united
states
you got one sitting right here and again
again
like you can't people like me can't win
if the people don't help right and i
mean like
you've got it like you got to contribute
to people's campaigns
otherwise otherwise you get bludgeoned
to death by big
party politics yes i want to just give a
shout out to iohk.io which is cardano's
website or one of them
i oh it's just so cool you go there and
you swipe around on it oh cool this is
so
like if this has anything to do with the
house no one can see what you're doing i
know i know but go there
when the podcast is over and check it
out and mouse around and swipe around
what does it do it's just this really
amazing graphical uh
layout and if this speaks dropping paint
and water yeah the creativity of the
designers and the developers i wonder if
this you know it just makes me have
faith in the developers as a whole all
right
it's pretty i've loved this for years
that's why obama got elected he was a
celebrity yeah that's flashy colorful
beautiful
all right let's see we just hit it
youtube just jumped on us
remote cfo says in my honest opinion
youtubers that claim they can make more
of a difference on youtube rather than
office is just a cop-out
tim i love you my korean brother but
your country needs you sean
pa is behind you awesome i'm sorry i
would would i
i don't know what i would do in office
sit around and complain
someone's attacking me on twitter for
not i didn't i i
i didn't know what the content of the
nfa like i know what the national i know
what this stuff
is but i didn't know what the hell you
were at i mean right yeah
people are deaf people give me no grace
twitter's dumb it's worth that way
daniel brun
bundrick says anytime someone suggests a
new law they're saying
there should be a new sword and good
though the sword may be
they don't get to decide who will wield
it we should choose our laws wisely and
assume they will be wielded by the worst
among us
i mean if you were to like take all the
laws in the u.s and put them in a book
the book would probably be like what
yeah 20 stories tall yes
that's insane people don't even know
what's illegal and they're like
ignorance is no excuse uh
actually it is it totally is that's the
most it's the stupidest thing i've heard
ignorance is no excuse for breaking a
lot bro i'm a law abiding citizen if i
knew i couldn't bake an apple pie on
sundays and put on my windows so i
wouldn't have done it
but that's insane you know some places
that's true like there's like some
places where you can't bathe on tuesdays
yeah
and people don't know that those laws
are still in the books and they expect
that the judges will just do the right
thing well what if they don't what if
they don't do the right thing
get those laws out of there what are you
doing i turn right on red in new york
i didn't know i lived there lived in l.a
lived to chicago where you can turn
right on red can't turn right on red in
new york
and then you get pulled over and they'll
give you a ticket and say ignorance is
no excuse yeah it's like okay
there's there's there's a lot of things
where you don't realize it's like
illegal like
for instance when people don't realize
about drones you can buy it best buy you
can own a best buy but i'll take a drone
place okay
and then you can fly it and then not
even realize it's breaking the laws like
i went to a toy store
over 400 feet yeah well they don't they
they restrict that kind of stuff but
there are certain things you might not
even realize
like like can you believe this you can't
climb into the tiger pen
at a zoo like who's supposed to know i'm
kidding don't do that one
don't do that no but there there are
some things where it's like
you uh so for instance my experience in
my um for me
i was driving back from colorado springs
fort carson
and they had suspended my license
without telling me because there was no
way they could have and no way for me to
know and i got in trouble for it
and i'm like what what is this i i had
no idea even happened
and i'm coming home before i even got my
mail and they're like so what
couldn't they have been like okay dude
don't drive again here's your official
warning
forget about it but you can't drive
because your license suspended i'd have
been like you got it boss
instead they're like we're arresting you
we'll see you in court and then went to
court they were like so
you confess and i was like bro just give
me the notification
the first thing that should happen is
the driver you should get pulled over by
a cop it should be like i'm giving you
formal notice your license has been
suspended
you have to exit your vehicle right now
if you're caught driving again it's on
your record
you will be arrested i'd be like you got
it mm-hmm something but ignorance is no
excuse like if someone
if a cop goes down the street and
tickets a bunch of cars and then some
like random person
comes up and then takes all the tickets
off all the cars yep too bad that's
illegal but you won't know that you got
a ticket
how what that's so bad you'll get a
ticket in the mail saying you failed to
appear or contest so you have a finalist
so crazy
yeah the system's got a bunch of
problems man i don't know i don't know
what we should do with it
we gotta we gotta just keep working i
suppose all right we'll do a couple more
here we got sam devlin he says i was
accepted to stockton u and nj
they're requiring vax by 8-1 students
only
or i can't start my fall classes even if
all are online
i refuse to bend the knee my mom is
going to be pissed need to find a new
program
well um why go to college
that's a good question yeah like what
what what are you going to college for
what
why go to college i would say if going
to college is something you have your
heart set on if it's
something like stem just so you know
vaccinations have always been required
by
all different kinds of schools for polio
mmr and all that stuff yeah so it's not
really new
and i'm not surprised by this as such i
don't know it's my two cents
it's a great point yeah i think college
is dumb in a waste of time
i think observatory kind of thing that
was cool i certainly don't think it's i
you know i i was raised you know and my
our generation's like oh you got to go
to school you got to go to school
and and i did i went to got my undergrad
got my masters don't do anything with it
um but um i think in today's day and age
you know it's hard you know it's it's
hard to find a plumber it's hard to find
carpenter it's hard to find people that
have actual trades and and those people
when they get jobs like they're making
80 90
100 bucks an hour you know um and there
are so many jobs
available and so i think learning a
trade moving forward
a manufacturing trade is something
that's just it's
really important right now was your
experience as a undergrad and
and you said you got your master's too
yeah uh did that help you get into
officer
school no um i i went through the art
after 9 11 i was i was an elementary
education major at clarion university
um wanting to teach second grade 911
happened
if happened geez a few days later was
down at the recruiter
joined the infantry it said i wanted to
join the infantry go to airborne school
ranger school transferred to duquesne
it's not covid it's not covenant believe
it um
transfer to duquesne and join the rotc
program
drink that water yeah all right
everybody's got some token
we get tons of super chats with like say
this token say this token
so many times
no financial advice here what's that
what's a token
so uh tokens are they they exist on
other
chains so like erc20 tokens are really
easy to make
you just like snatch your fingers and
make a bunch of tokens it's kind of like
we should never
read super chat token shout outs right i
avoid them for the most part
because everyone's always does everyone
have a token now it's so
easy to make tokens you snap your
fingers and you can do it yeah oh yep
like literally just so why
why would why would someone why does
some people want to do i could make
beanie coin right now pump and dump it
would operate on the ethereum network
i could just snap my fingers and make it
probably take what like 10 minutes you
think i don't know i've never done it
before 10 minutes
and then i could make like okay beanie
coin has a million coins
i keep a hundred thousand for myself and
then i just disperse the coins
you know by by some metric or whatever
and then or
people can start proof of staking to
generate coins or something
and then once the coin is worth a penny
i have you know a thousand dollars or
whatever
so people will make a token with 450
million
total capacity or something and then
it's money or they'll buy like a million
tokens and then super chat
for 50 bucks like hey this token hope
that it goes up
50 percent and they make which is
basically just like scamming
smokes yeah it's very pump and dump it's
very disturbing wow
powerful tech but disturbing well
there's no regulation
which is partly the good thing i mean
buyer beware right caveat emptor
is that what it is i don't know is that
that sounds roman caveat
it's latin for sure yeah the buyer
beware yeah
all right player says tried to go to his
website
says the ip could not be reached on
chrome
is your website blocked on chrome no
interesting
definitely brave and duckduckgo is your
browser and search engine
i mean it's coming it's no what
try it is it working on chrome andrew's
a chrome guy
all right let me read this one gavin
mcdougall says hedge funds are
liquidating assets including crypto
in anticipation of having to pay out on
amc not because elon talks crap
yeah the the the big squeeze everyone's
excited is claiming it's gonna be a big
hedge fund squeeze
and bill gates is panicking and there's
a bunch of conspiracy theories i don't
know what's gonna happen
we wanna see it we'll see man yeah
but my friends for those that are
listening smash the like button if you
haven't done so already because it
really does help and sharing this
channel
and these videos they always help you
can follow us on facebook at
facebook.com
timcast irl where we are posting clips
from the show
and with your help sharing them we can
leverage the facebook network to drive
people to you know our website
and the same thing is true for face uh
for tim cast irl on instagram which is
that same name
this show is live monday through friday
at 8 pm so don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member a bonus
segment is coming up
shortly is there anything you want to
shout out sean shout out to me oh
shout out please go to my website
parnellforsenate.com
if you have the means contribute join
the movement we need your help
uh or follow me on twitter at sean
parnell usa
it's really great man love having you
here it was really interesting i love
being here man
i love being just joy uh you can follow
me at ian crossland.net and at ian
crosson on social media
thank you sean gives me a lot of hope
for kind of the gop in general so it's
really nice to hear these
more sane reasonable approaches and i'm
really hoping that you're the guy who
gets in and fights like heck
to make good things happen me too
because i love this country
and it's worth fighting for and it's
worth defending yeah 100
you can follow me on twitter at sarah
patch lids and i'm on a journey to have
more followers and sour patch kids
very important please join me it's a lot
of fun
we will see you all at timcast.com at
about 11 p.m so thanks for hanging out
and we will see you there bye guys
you